a couple of days ago I was hearing some
murmurs I think it made me a couple days
ago about project Veritas but nothing
confirmed but now we do have
confirmation that James O'Keefe has been
placed on paid leave
several employees signed a letter
complaining about his behavior
calling him a tyrant the strange thing
about this letter is that they say that
many of the signees never actually
witnessed any abuse nor experienced any
of it but decided to sign the letter
anyway turns out that one of the
individuals involved who may have been
about to get fired has pronouns in his
bio leading many people to believe that
this is some kind of coup to remove
James O'Keefe and now project Veritas
has put out a new video with a different
host explaining what's going on with
their story yeah and no one's buying it
no one's heard from James so of course
this is is a huge story and uh we gotta
get into it we'll talk about that plus
we'll talk about what's going on with uh
what we got Facebook reinstating Donald
Trump we've got a bunch of different
stories but uh we're gonna get into it
ladies and gentlemen we're gonna we're
gonna talk about some strange censorship
that's going on with a person who was
recently on this show named Eliza blue
and I know the chat's gonna light up but
for those of you who aren't familiar
this got to a point where admittedly
within the past hour I said okay okay
look you you guys you know the people
who have been asking us politely I might
add that took to consider looking into
this we just saw several people others
who other individuals have been in the
show who have had a series of YouTube
videos taken down and so I will say in
honor of the polite requests uh I think
it's actually worth talking about and I
also want to say too that
look what what's happened with project
veritas
had me actually very worried James
O'Keefe we haven't heard from what's
going on we've had the drama with the
daily wire and Stephen Crowder obviously
there was drama involving me which I
just I feel like all of this it's
getting a little out of hand it's
getting a little crazy especially
considering this other story that we
have two Republicans in New Jersey were
just killed in the past week now one was
by a co-worker we're not entirely sure
what the motive was another individual
was targeted this woman in her vehicle
and that made me kind of take stock of
everything and just say okay look man we
we've got to make sure that at the very
least if we have differences we're
unified in what these problems really
are because it seems like this is really
really bad considering project Veritas
recently did one of the biggest exposes
of their existence with James O'Keefe
and then almost immediately immediately
after we see him get ousted in some kind
of coup attempt or I should say outright
coup and uh at least that's what I'm
hearing from sources in in New York
media seems like a coup at project
Veritas yeah I I think we have we've
gotta make sure at the very least I ask
and uh that we focus so I'm gonna say
this outright you know for anybody who's
upset with me I apologize for being
Brash and crass I said I wasn't gonna
but I'm genuinely freaked out watching
what's happening with Veritas seeing the
infighting between Crowder and daily
wire and then now this kind of makes me
feel that look I'm not perfect and y'all
can still be mad at me but I don't want
to engage in any fighting that's going
to cause us to actually lose this thing
in the long run because it's not a good
thing you know last night we had a great
show with members of Congress we got to
keep this energy up and we got to make
sure that even if we disagree on certain
things we're we're focused in the in the
same direction towards making things
better and and fighting for the values
that we have so you know considering
what we're seeing now with Chrissy Mayer
as well I'll be happy to admit that I
was wrong about this one for sure but I
do have some grievances that I'm I'm
planning to address that I think some
people should be aware about as it
pertains to the story but we'll get into
that before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member to support
our work as a member you'll get access
to exclusive uncensored members only
shows from this podcast they go up
around 11 P.M Monday through Thursday
and we did an awesome show you know Matt
Gates comes in swing and swearing and uh
we had a really great uncensored show
with several members of Congress in the
office of Lauren bobert last night check
that one out and we're going to have one
tonight for you as well you're also
helping us with our cultural Endeavors
we're setting up a coffee shop a
physical physical location where people
can hang out we'll talk all about that
and uh it's underway we got the contract
stuff happening a lot of expansion is
currently happening so it's all very
much exciting and I think you know I
just want to make sure we can focus on
that positive energy and
um this admittedly look man this Veritas
stuff is really creepy because some
people are suggesting that he's being
ousted by some malicious external forces
so we'll get in all that stuff joining
us today to talk about this and so much
more is we got Reed and Jose from the
tower gang how's it going man it's going
well thanks for having me on Tim who are
you uh yeah well I'm read Coverdale I
have
um my own show called The naturalist
capitalist and basically talk about how
the government ruins everything it
touches everybody's trying to fix small
problems and they create bigger problems
uh once a month I do the four horsemen
show wearing the show here with my
friend Ryan Dawson and Eric Jackman we
talk about conspiracy theories foreign
policy current events and then the rest
of the time I'm just talking about uh
work related stuff how the government's
destroyed the working industry made it
harder for working people
um you know I talked I have foreign
policy experts on and lots of people you
guys have had on friends with Scott
Horton and Dave Smith and those guys
have a lot of those people on
um and then I do social media for the
libertarian party on New Hampshire and
we're constantly making headlines over
there and stirring things up so
um yeah that's it that's me how about
you bro and I'm Jose gellison I I'm part
of tower gang which is an offensive
comedy podcast so if you come in there
and say I'm offended just know we don't
care and we'll probably laugh at you uh
I also have the no way Jose show uh
that's more I do my more serious content
I cover libertarian Theory uh
conspiracies generally whatever just
interests me it's just kind of my outlet
for that uh probably the thing I'm best
known for is my coverage of the OKC
Oklahoma City bombing thing uh that's
why I have the shirt on uh Terence hiki
didn't kill himself that's what dragged
me into it the character of terenciki
was an American hero uh he had a very
incredulous death and oh we ruled the
suicide immediately and uh I think he uh
I think he's an American hero that needs
to be remembered and I think there are
people out there that need to be held to
account for his death
right on we also got philabonti back in
the house what's up everybody I am back
from the Left Coast I am uh philabonti
uh lead vocalist for All That Remains I
don't know Jose or Reed and uh I disavow
everything they have to say the second
part of that's true it's too late my
friend Ian hi everyone Ian Crossing
coming at you I've got some good news on
bucko he came back from his uh vet's uh
Journey today and he's gained a quarter
pound in the last week wow that's a lot
for a little fella but it is a lot for a
guy his size is very promising man stem
cell technology stem cells in state of
mind it's been very calm peaceful the
prayers yes I tell him how good he is
how healthy he is how I'm lucky to be
with them and he seems to enjoy when I
start doing push-ups he gets up and
starts moving around and eating and
eating big meats bucko's doing well uh I
think that's all I got to start off Jose
you and I did an episode of no way Jose
yeah we sure did it was a while back I
was approaching you for my Erica's
handbook series seeing if you're into
proton you weren't but we still had a
great episode right right I didn't know
enough about the context of the data but
maybe we can get into it tonight if we
do go that direction I don't know we'll
find out and we also have this gorgeous
human to my right did you get a haircut
yeah I was gonna I was not gonna say
anything about it
just not address it on the podcast you
know but I did get a haircut uh you
check out the pop culture crisis from
today if you want to see me get my hair
cut that was good okay very handsome
wouldn't me thank you guys all right
let's jump to this first story this one
uh this story legit has me freaked out
uh I was hearing some some rumors and
some murmurs from timcast.com James
O'Keefe accused of erratic Behavior by
16 project Veritas employees James has
become a Power drunk Tyrant said one
unnamed employee in a letter submitted
to the organization's board nobody's
buying it
uh I've got my sources and uh I'm not
buying it this is the letter that we
were able to obtain through uh let me
just say sources in New York media
apparently this had been circulating to
a certain degree and I want you to know
a few things one this letter is signed
by I believe was it 16 employees
accusing James O'Keefe of being a power
drunk Tyrant and he is exactly who he
pontificates on who we should be
exposing now this letter includes very
important bits of information and
context which leads me to believe
I think there are people trying to oust
James O'Keefe not because of any of
these perceived grievances I think
they're trying to just remove him as an
element of project Veritas because I
mean he's the guy he is veritas
I would put it this way if you're an
organization with 65 employees and you
generate Millions Plus in in donor
Revenue
I imagine the board members are thinking
like hey the one problem we have in
terms of control of this money is James
O'Keefe he's an ideological figurehead
who believes in a mission and founded
this this happens with with big
companies all the time it's like in
Spider-Man remember when Willem Dafoe is
playing uh Harry Osborne and he's like
do you have any idea how much time
sacrificed they're getting rid of them
you get rid of James O'Keefe from this
com from this organization and you are
free to use that money however you see
fit the problem is I don't think
anyone's going to support them now as we
mentioned they're saying that they were
bullied that he's a tyrant let me let me
read for you the top note because they
certainly had to include this it says
the opinions data shared and anecdotes
were compiled by one-third of the
project Veritas staff representing every
Department not all signed this letter
but all had compelling reason to
contribute some signatories have not
been the subject of abuse nor witnessed
any abuse but found the corroborated
Behavior troubling and were willing to
sign
that that means right there sounds like
a load of garbage to me so what did they
sign exactly so imagine this you work at
project Veritas
someone walks up to you and says we
think James O'Keefe is bad and he's done
these things will you sign a letter and
they say sure
next thing you know the board comes
together there's a viral Twitter thread
where one guy is saying uh reporting
according to his sources
one of the board members who
orchestrated this had a whole thing
scripted in ousting James O'Keefe so
I've reached out to James I've not heard
from him but uh admittedly look man you
know when I saw this and a few other
stories today I was like dude
this I got questions man it's it's
getting crazy right now okay so if first
of all if you sign your name to a paper
that's making a statement that's an
indication that you are making the
statement and if you didn't see the
things that you're signing on to that's
fraud or at least could be construed as
fraud so don't sign something that you
don't believe in I think that's what the
disclaimer's for though isn't it to make
sure that they to say look I'm I didn't
see this but there was a disclaimer
saying that I didn't see it well I think
that James is a bad person it it needs
to be more fleshed out than just an
introduction with like some of these
people like it needs to be on the
signatories you need to see who didn't
see it who is just following along and
signing for the fun or because they feel
like okay and who actually witnessed the
things that needs to be very implicit
and it's what it is is sign this if you
don't like him okay that's really what
it isn't that the vibe that that you
pick up it's essentially it's like
people that have some kind of incentive
to not work for James O'Keefe whether it
be people that want control of project
Veritas like on the board or whatever if
he's inhibiting activities they want you
know because he is ideological which is
the point of project Veritas like the
whole point of it is he's ideological
and and they're looking to you know
uncover bias and stuff
um so I I think that it's it's it seems
like it's all emotionally motivated uh
you know with people that have some kind
of uh you know some kind of benefit from
Jane from James or keep not running
project Veritas to play Devil's Advocate
uh on the side of the people that are
creating this letter because I love
James and his work is that maybe in the
last year stress has been getting to
James like I feel like I can empathize
with what he's been going through the
last year like he I saw him tweet out
like I'm not suicidal by the way like
you don't tweet that out if you're not
stressed out like no no no I don't I
don't buy it look at this
I don't believe this I literally don't
believe it I've had people saying like
Tim must be so stressed out and it's
like dude I'm I'm like people make up
stories about you man look at this
democracy Partners trial in public I was
yelled at in front of jurors because he
was hungry and then he took the
eight-month pregnant woman sandwich like
come on man like am I supposed to
believe that James O'Keefe like walked
into an eight-month pregnant woman was
like give me your sandwich I'm hungry
and snatched it from her that that
sounds like something someone made up to
make him sound bad right because if I
take something from you it could be
because I went over and grabbed it out
of your hand or it could be because you
offered it to me and then I took it
sorry that I really don't think I don't
think that the person that's accusing
James I don't think they're saying that
the child gave him the sandwich I think
there's a pregnant woman oh okay so well
I still I don't feel like she might have
been like hungry can I have that and
she's like okay maybe I'm wrong on your
on your suicide point I mean I'd have to
know the context but I know it's a
common thing like literally just I start
out from the beginning with the yiki
thing about the suicide so I don't know
the context in which he said it it could
have been like a snarky remark with okay
Chief with the kind of things he covered
he's obviously alluding like hey if
something happens to me it wasn't me
that's exactly it was like a tweet yeah
like he just said in a tweet like a
couple sentences elon's been doing some
similar things I'm sure he's under an
immense amount of stress right now I
I've talked about how people claimed I
went to their house in Boston and walked
in their house two in the morning and
turned the TV on and people tweet that
kind of stuff and they believe it I look
at this and I'm like James walked up to
a pregnant woman and stole her sandwich
that's the thing take is not steel she
might have asked her and she said yes
that's what not been happy about so so
so consider this too it may be that so
they're greatly exaggerating these
things look man I got I kind of feel
like
I'll put it this way I work for
nonprofits imagine you have an
organization founded by somebody else
they're ideologically driven we have a
mission this is what we're going to do
and this is why we do it and you're like
I want five million dollars in cash this
organization's got 50 million bucks but
James won't let me pay myself we got to
get rid of James these are the kind of
thing that happens when these are the
kind of things that happen at big
companies after a long period of time
they want to get rid of the person in
charge who's motivated by a mission
there's a saying that um there a buddy
of mine was an entrepreneur said some
people are good at starting companies
and some people are good at running
companies some people are founders some
people are CEOs somebody founds a
company and then they hand it off to the
CEO the CEOs are very different from the
founders so my view of this is just my
personal opinion and my bias because
like when I I mean the sandwich thing
really is there and then there's also
some other there's something else I want
to show you if I would let me first ask
you guys this
when you think of project Veritas who do
you think of James okay hands down yeah
James O'Keefe is Project Veritas that's
not what they think they're they're
here's here's an image look at this
there is honestly no project Veritas
without us you know look partially true
this is our moment to make history I
hope James can realize we're doing this
out of love for the mission yeah that's
that's all that's all created in their
own head if when they start saying that
they're doing things for out of love
that are bad for a person that's
rationalizing doing something they know
is immoral and bad so I'm um I think
that Tim's right on I think that they're
they're motivated I work pretty tough
love oh no I was thinking like this
abruptly I don't know I worked for
several non-profits all right not in
this context and here's what happens
because these organizations don't
function like the same kind of companies
people who work here work for a mission
they're not part of the reason you get
paid less when you work in a non-profit
is because you're doing something you
want to do for a mission and so at every
single non-profit Office I work these
are all events fundraising Street
campusing Etc
they had a policy all of them to fire
every single person in the office the
moment a person starts expressing
demoralization I mean like morale
and so the fear was if somebody starts
getting upset and feeling aggravated or
aggrieved they'll go to a person in
another room and go you know what's
going on man I don't like nothing what
are you doing I'm just I'm so sick of
this man you know James was talking to
me and I'm tired of it man like you know
what I'm talking about right James you
have yeah you know I mean sometimes and
then what happens is the negativity and
the demoralization starts spreading from
person to person where they get angrier
and angrier then they all start going to
each other
this this has happened at every office
I've worked my argument's always been
you need to have a company-wide meeting
you need to have a pizza party you need
to make people feel good you can't just
fire everybody but this is what they do
they churn and burn they they just burn
through people
I'm wondering if a component of this is
somebody who wants James O'Keefe ousted
from the organization wants control of
the assets and resources is going around
telling people like yeah like that that
time he yelled at you remember and
they're like oh yeah and they took that
woman's sandwich yeah yeah he did do
that and then a week later they're like
remember when you told me you told me
that he yelled at you and took that
woman sandwich yeah we wrote that down
signed the paper and they go oh okay the
thing is once you make accusations
against people too regardless of what
the truth is and regardless of how easy
it is to disprove it they'll run with
that narrative so in New Hampshire for
example there was this uh Senate Senator
race going on there was uh don balduck
against Maggie Hassan and joa from
breaking the flaw who's a co-host on
free talk live with me he was at this
protest and he was definitely you know
being annoying and getting in people's
faces but he never touched anybody never
laid a hand on anyone and Don baldick
basically just lied and said that he
attacked him and hit him
and um you know there was video footage
of everything that was going on and we
released it from the libertarian party
in New Hampshire showing that they never
touch each other at all or anything but
it just ran with it and then the
Democrats were picking it up too even
though they could use this as an attack
against baldwick they knew that it you
know it would have been very easy to say
like look this guy isn't telling the
truth but just because a narrative was
put out there it's impossible to
disprove it even if you have all the
video footage and everything so well
there's that's because there's a there's
a motivated block of people to the
motive a block of people that are
motivated to believe it or it needs to
spread it even if they don't actually
believe it pylon culture yeah which is
like it's it's a tough justification to
not utilize false accusations against
your enemy because it's like they're
your enemy and you need to win if if
it's the combat State of Mind conflict
anything to get the job done in those
situations but when like the culture
when you're having communication it's
like I mean I know that desire like I
want this so bad that I'm willing to
accept falsehoods to get it it's just
not the right ethics I think that's
sloppy tactics though I think that the
move if you're smart you sit back you
value the battlefield you wait you find
something accurate something that will
literally pierce the enemy's heart if
you will and that's what you go for like
I mean obviously maybe you can make
disinformation or work you for you
sometimes but I think in the long run
it's a failing strategy but sometimes
it's just a really long run yeah she
would go faster I'm not so confident
that it actually is a failing strategy
uh yeah I mean it All is fair and Love
and War is a phrase for a reason uh
underhanded tactics frequently work even
if they're under underhanded and I think
that you see that in modern politics
pretty clearly I mean it's not it's not
rare for a politician to lie about their
opponent or to exaggerate or to pick up
a republican that attacks a republican
it's not unusual for a Democrat to pick
up the the attack if the person is
leading you know so I really do think
that the the all's fair and Love and War
thing is is predominant and yeah but at
least this particular issue but how do
people feel about the government right
now how do they feel about Congress you
know I mean that's my long it might be
it's a it's a kind of how much your time
preference how long are you willing to
look out in the future so here we are
now we're like the Congress is like it's
like lowest level ever but everyone
hates Congress for different reasons you
asked you ask most people and they are
happy with their own Congress people the
people they don't like are the Congress
people that get in the way of the
policies that their congressperson is
looking to you know looking to push
forward after last night we did a show
at Congress and Lauren bobert's office I
gained a new love for those people and
that building and the the Congress
itself it felt very inviting like it it
it a lot of people really want to do
good and they have different tactics
There's real invitings really hard not
to make a January 6th joke it was
shocking how how at home I felt there
how like good it felt the people are
like at this level of what we talk about
on the show kind of like all of them are
at this I think then I guess there's a
lot of probably older Congress people
that aren't fired up and those people
are just like you know playing paying
the bill to get by I'm not as interested
in that mentality but the Young people
that want to provoke change and and stop
crazy change is like I'm all on board
with that so my my Congress approval
rating is up after yesterday personally
wow uh but I will point out we're not at
War this is not a war so if people are
using false accusations to get James
ousted it's not war and all is not fair
in in legal battles so if they're doing
something underhanded I think that
that's going to get some people in a lot
of trouble
um so we have this uh video here and
it's from Project Veritas and I don't
know who this guy is it's uh it says
busted Pfizer CEO Albert borla relies on
aggressive security tactics to escape
Veritas journalists questions do you
know who this guy is I'm not trying to
be a dick to him I don't know he is
what's his name Albert this no this guy
right here this journalist that they
have not yet so I people started telling
me hey you know they they removed James
O'Keefe stripped him of his authority
put him on paid leave
have explained almost nothing we had to
get leaked this this letter explaining
what people were claiming which sounds
outlandish and we've not gotten a
response from James then they put out a
video with some other dude we I don't
know really James lolino project James
we're standing outside the Conrad Hotel
in Washington DC I just gotta say this
you know isn't it doesn't it I tweeted
this morning that all the drama was part
of a plan because I was joking and it
was people took me seriously I said I
was like this Stephen Crowder on The
Daily wire and Tim to me in the
quartering and veritas and James O'Keefe
you don't think it's a coincidence do
you phase two begins soon and then
people like thought I was being serious
I was just pointing out like why is all
of this stuff happening right now yeah
and then of course you know
later in the day you know I put out an
apology to Jeremy because
I I don't I don't think any of us have
any differences in the level of you know
what our what our real cultural and
ideological battles are in the culture
war and with politics like there's no
real reason for me to be you know
personally mad at German like that like
bickering like this like and I'll say
that for me like I've I have no reason
to even bring it up sure if he was
trying to put microchips in you and
track your movement then I'd say you
speak up or you know sterilize kids yeah
and things like that that's why I'm like
watching the Veritas stuff watching the
Crowder stuff and all of this happening
in the past couple of weeks and these
other stories about people get these
Republicans getting shot I'm kind of
like hey yo let's not like I I don't
know man look you all can tell me I'm
wrong about everything you can insult me
you can say uh Tim you you did bad I
will accept all of that I don't want
this to fall apart I will I will gladly
accept you can unsubscribe you can
unfollow you can not be a member anymore
I will I will gladly step back and say
the worst possible thing right now with
all of this going on is infighting and
I'm and and you know I'm sorry I don't
want this to happen I don't want things
to get worse this freaks me out so I'm
sure there's like multiple levels of
drama but um as far as the right having
this Civil War I'm actually extremely
glad it's happening I think Jose might
agree with me because it seems to be
separating the wheat from the chaff in a
lot of ways like this whole DeSantis
versus Trump stuff that's going on and
just seeing everyone turn on each other
uh seeing you know Matt Gates actually
stand up against
um McCarthy being elected speakers stuff
like that like it's uncomfortable but
it's actually kind of like forcing the
right to evolve if you know what I mean
it is but you know the reason I I think
Matt Gates is fantastic yes I said this
on the show the other day and he brought
it up that he's my favorite member of
Congress and I'm like well look man he
defended ilhan Omar someone he shouldn't
on a principled ground that made sense
and I respect that and then he voted to
have her removed on a logical ground
that made sense and I'm like I get what
he's doing he so you know he said he
gives speaker McCarthy an a rating now
they stood up they did what they had to
do they they they stood up on principle
when it came to swallow well and shift
being removed from their committees he
said that makes sense they lied about
intelligence I agree he said removing
ilhan Omar because she's had things you
don't like doesn't seem to make sense it
doesn't sit well with me however he'll
hand Omar voted to remove Marjorie
Taylor green and gosar so that's the
standard she set so he's I'm like that's
actually logical that makes sense I can
respect that tremendously so when
looking at the the McCarthy stuff
that I'm in favor of you know them
standing up to the establishment saying
we get these concessions but I don't see
any net gain in all of us at the base
level fighting with each other at all I
I don't I don't see
any of us succeeding if all all of a
sudden the exact same time we all find
reason to have beef with each other you
know what I mean it helps you identify
good faith actors in my opinion yeah
that's that's really yeah I know it
splits things up and it to me I see I
see like crisises and stuff like it's
almost inevitable I think you're almost
better to make the best of it and what
this was was this was a you're able to
identify things from here you're able to
see who your in group was who your
outgroup was uh who's willing to act in
good faith who's not I mean that's not
safe there are perfect actors on the
inside but you can tell uh I mean
throughout all this drama there has been
so many crazy claims and it allows you
to be like yeah I probably won't work
with that person probably not gonna
interact with them et cetera et cetera
you don't have to cause a problem over
it but it allows you to be able to see
the battlefield what's going on et
cetera et cetera yeah this is this is
the the challenge that I basically see
with all of this stuff is you know Vera
this should not be happening in veritas
at all if they've got problems with
James O'Keefe they should not have
handled this way this is this is
horrible mismanagement made me take
stock of what I was doing and I'm like I
shouldn't be so reckless and Brash and
and arrogant at the same because like I
see that and then it reflects on me what
am I doing this is a this is a bad way
to handle it especially if we're trying
to be strategic and tactful so that we
can focus on issues like I don't know
people smuggling eggs over the Mexican
border because the prices are so insane
like things we actually have to
accomplish because we're concerned that
they're letting non-citizens vote in
Washington DC or New York or are
outright as many people are pointing out
censorship due to people filing false
privacy claims or legal challenges
exploiting the system to gain some kind
of political power and I can respect
that so at that point I'm just like
yeah we that I I'm genuinely freaked out
not to mention you know what really does
it is like we can have drama and
whatever and I'm kind of like whatever
and then I see these two Republicans in
Jersey get killed and I'm kind of like
okay guys let's let's get serious we're
you know we're let's let's get serious
yeah we're lucky to be able to
experience drama in a conversational way
that's we're very privileged in this
Society be able to Hash it out with
words before it would ever come to
anything other than that we can we can
you know I put it this way I might I
meant you you mentioned it allows you to
see who you might not want to work with
and who you want to work with we can see
the camps right the audience sizes here
and a different audience here and
there's some overlap and some people get
mad this way and some people get mad
that way and I'm just like but why are
we mad at each other I should I
shouldn't be be doing that because the
people over there are doing really
messed up stuff they're lying to the
American people they're spreading false
intelligence they're putting ankle
weights on a president who gave us the
best economic numbers in a generation
and then resulted in us getting a Joe
Biden who gives us some of the worst and
I'm kind of like yeah I I think we've
gotta we've got to make sure we're
focused on that stuff you know I oh I
was thinking well you go for it you
triggered him with the uh Trump
economics oh yeah well I mean I do have
to address that I mean we were
definitely when Trump ran for president
in 2016 he even said we're living in a
bubble it's gonna pop this isn't
actually a good economy until he was
President then suddenly it was the
greatest economy in the world until it
crashed when he's gone you know I don't
think that has much to do with uh Trump
or Biden or Obama it's more about the
Federal Reserve policies we had over
that time but that aside I think it's
important I think the fox in the hen or
the the wolf in sheep's clothing is more
dangerous than the fox in the hen house
so like an obvious enemy me is less of a
threat because it's easy to point out
it's easy to say this person is
dangerous and they're against what we
stand for when you have somebody I would
say like Trump who virtue signals on a
lot of important issues but then nine
times out of ten when it comes down to
it he goes along with whatever the
establishment wants I think that's more
dangerous I mean under Biden you've had
legitimate right-wing opposition to what
he's been doing if Trump were still
president right now I don't think you'd
have nearly the amount of
solidified
um opposition to what's going on in the
white house I mean because we saw that
in 2020. when you look at wage wages and
inflation right when Joe Biden gets put
right when Joe Biden gets inaugurated
then right after he enacts a plethora of
executive orders you start to see a
dramatic shift in wages starting to go
down sure and inflation's starting to go
up so you think that's a coincidence no
I don't think it's coincidence I mean
the cares Act was the largest spending
bill in U.S history signed by Donald
Trump in March of 2020 the covid Relief
act of 2020 was the second largest
spending Bill signed into law by
President Trump in December of 2020 and
so sure Biden's energy policy does
nothing to help it definitely makes it
worse but to act like printing trillions
and trillions of dollars out of midair
when we had a Republican president and
locking the economy down which wasn't
his fault I'm not blaming him I mean it
was Democrat Governors sure well
Republican Governors too yeah both but
to act like that wouldn't have you know
effects regardless of whether or not he
gets elected like even if Donald Trump
got reelected and was still president
you would have 95 of this inflation the
inflation is increasing the money supply
I mean I I agree to the extent that the
spending was bad but also you take a
look at the for one like obviously the
energy policy of of Joe Biden but you
take a look at a whole bunch of other
things I mean they're they're they're
enacting policy based on ideological
ends Joe Biden literally said he was
going to end fossil fuels before the
pandemic the the economy was the best
numbers of Our Lives obviously not
during the pandemic so if you get a
knee-jerk reaction that results in Mass
spending and panic but you have a
tendency among democrats for Harsh and
total lockdown you get a Joe Biden who
starts speaking about the lockdowns only
to Blue States and not red States and
then you know previous to this you had
some red States saying no and opening
back up you get a Joe Biden that comes
into office and acts a bunch of uh
policies you get the inflation reduction
act quote unquote and then you watch in
real time as inflation continually gets
worse stagnates at extremely high levels
or continues to get worse yeah I think
if Donald Trump was President we
probably have better academic policy I
think things would probably be recovered
well you got a DeSantis because you had
Biden I don't think he would have had a
DeSantis under Trump DeSantis and I've
got lots of issues with DeSantis but
when he was opposing the coveted regime
in Florida where Jose is living
um I think a lot of that was because
there was political will to have a
dissenter to the you know the official
narrative that Joe Biden was putting out
with Donald Trump I think that would
have been a lot less likely I think if
you have a central authority figure that
people can hate and they can actually
oppose not just like in a virtue
signaling way and not just in an
emotional way but actually come out
against it that's how you get an action
I think a good example of what breed's
getting at is just a quick little thing
the majority of gun control gets pushed
through under Republican presence and
the reason why is because exactly what
he's saying when you have someone like
abide in an office you actually get a
legitimate Republican pushback whereas
you have somebody like a a conservative
in office you know they're able to push
through these huge bills or these things
would typically be not conservative
because like no one wants to rock the
boat I just want to clarify that if I
had to compare Joe Biden with Donald
Trump I do prefer Donald Trump's
policies to Joe Biden I'm just talking
you're from your reactionary you're
coming at it from a libertarian's
perspective sure so the the underlying
statement that you're making is Donald
Trump is not a Libertarian which I don't
think he's not even a republican well I
mean he's he's a he's a progressive
Republican probably along he's a 90s
Democrat yeah that's and that's fair and
that's fine but
if you're arguing that
Donald Trump is not libertarian enough
for you that's a legitimate argument
because Donald Trump wasn't trying to be
libertarian well it's fair to say that
Donald Trump isn't libertarian enough
for libertarian people and and I I mean
most your criticisms I agree because I
think you know I I prefer a smaller
government but holding Donald Trump to
the libertarian standard and saying well
he's not a Libertarian when everybody
that's a Donald Trump support is going
to go duh we don't care I don't think
that's you know what I mean that's not
my argument my partner play between the
different parties my argument is
actually to achieve libertarian policies
is easier on a state level under Joe
Biden than it would be under Donald
Trump because it's easier to Rally
opposition to Joe Biden like stuff
that's happened in Florida stuff that's
happened in New Hampshire it's very easy
because it's easy to rile up your
right-wing neighbor and say do you want
Joe Biden to be able to have Federal
jurisdiction over what happens in New
Hampshire and they'll say hell no and
they'll you know let's bring up this
story then sure we have this from
timcast.com second in new New Jersey
Republican elected officials shot and
killed within a week authorities have
not identified a motive but confirmed
the victim was the intended target this
is Milford Borough councilman Russell
Heller was murdered by a co-worker at a
PS Eng facility so we don't know exactly
why maybe it's not political perhaps but
we also had Eunice dwemfer who was shot
to death in a vehicle outside her home
and when asked if this was political the
D.A said that they didn't uh you know
they said something along uh to the
effect of you know please don't make you
know we don't want to answer that right
now or something something like that
so I don't know if this is political
but uh we certainly are seeing extremist
rhetoric we just had a bunch of leftist
storm into a capital building oh
Insurrection or whatever and uh in the
previous segment we were talking about
uh Reid you were mentioning that it's
easier to drum up opposition to uh write
like legitimate opposition to Joe Biden
to get in Republican or libertarian
policies because you have you know that
the president and it would be a lot more
difficult under Trump but I guess
looking at this I kind of feel like even
with a President Joe Biden the media is
still screaming the right is the Deep
threat you still have I mean is it a
coincidence that two Republican elected
officials were just shot and killed in
New Jersey in one week
maybe
um is it political it might not be I'm
kind of leaning towards two Republican
officials being shot and killed in the
span of a week I'd at least lean towards
the hypothesis we should look into
whether this is political considering
the rhetoric from the media and
everything like that so if we've got a
democrat in office shouldn't shouldn't
things be calming down at least as far
as the leftist rhetoric is it's it's
more hyped up and amped up than ever
yeah well I think the evolutionaries
that we have to worry about I think the
hyped up rhetoric is what causes a lot
of the right wing opposition to the
Democrats at church so for example like
people who didn't pay attention to
politics at all four years ago after the
last two years when they're suddenly a
science denying uh you know conspiracy
theorist or whatever and they're an
enemy of intelligence agencies or
whatever suddenly they start to care
about FBI the the FBI having as much
power as it does they start caring about
how much control the government has over
what you can put into your body all
these different things so yes there is a
lot more political
turmoil but I think that that has
actually woken up a lot of people who
wouldn't have said things that sound
like what I say nowadays four years ago
they never would have dreamed of it but
now it's just their regular rhetoric
because they've become so used Shifting
the Overton window yes the chaos kind of
produced by a weak president forces
people to establish local order if you
don't it won't they won't do it for you
I think yeah that's part of it too I
mean that's not what I meant but that's
part of it too is the weakness of Joe
Biden uh people gravitate toward their
governor if their governor is you know
strong and I I I like that
decentralization I would rather people
you know invest in their own state
government instead of worrying about
what the federal government's doing I'm
with you on the wolf in sheep's clothing
being more dangerous than the fox and
the hen house except that the the the
the obvious fool here Joe I'm calling
you out because you surrender to the
Taliban the the absolute mishandling of
our military and the loss of life
accrued by Joe Biden
and he surrendered to China the fact
that he allowed the balloon to just
cross the the country without doing
anything and now it's coming out that
there that that they were monitoring and
there was uh radio frequencies that they
were monitoring the China I mean he's
neglected the National Security the
National Security of the U.S entirely so
it has caused people to step up at a
local level and take control of their
lives but whether or not we're better
off having a weak president I don't know
because that loss of life in Afghanistan
is absolute that's going to hang on I
just got to talk about Afghanistan real
quick because the problem with
Afghanistan is that we stayed too long
Joe by uh sorry Donald Trump made a deal
with the Taliban that we would be out of
Afghanistan I think it was May 1st of
2020 was that 2021 yeah 2021 yeah yep
and then Joe Biden came in and he was an
arrogant ass and he said no we are going
to leave on September 11th because I'm
not gonna have Donald Trump's stupid
Afghanistan withdrawal plan so he stayed
an extra what four and a half months no
didn't get people out than the Taliban
that's not the pro that's not the
problem with with Afghanistan the
problem with that with with Afghanistan
was he got the combat troops out what
you do is you point guns at all the bad
guys and get your people out and leave
the guys with the guns pointed at the
bad guys on the ground and the guys with
the gun with the guns they leave last
everybody out and that was the problem
so it wasn't being killed on cars
outside the Air Force Base by Taliban he
abandoned Bagram Air Force Base yeah I
mean if you want to withdraw from
Afghanistan and I agree like we should
not have been there we should have been
there at all yeah but the one thing you
do is you tell the local security
Partners this the Afghan forces hey go
set up security over the next two weeks
to lock down the Air Force Base to
secure these areas uh they needed to
make sure they had logistics for their
for the for their aircraft for the
helicopters for the for the Jets or
whatever they're using one of the
problems we heard was that there were
people Afghan Security Forces literally
flying at the time when Biden abandoned
the country and all of a sudden all
their Logistics get cut off and they
have no idea what's going on the Taliban
without communication there was no
Defense Force and so we learned in the
middle of the night they abandoned the
Air Force Base say nothing and locals
went in and started looting the place
they gave everything to the Taliban
that's why I called a surrender literal
you surrender equipment or items or
people well what Reid and Jose are
talking about is strategy which is the
way that you know Biden came in and
wanted to have the the exit on September
11th for a look but the major problem
with withdrawal from Afghanistan was
tactical it was the way that they
actually did it they didn't set security
to get the the
non-combatants out to get the get the
people that were helping the Americans
whether they be Afghans or whether they
be other other countries or whatever the
net of the U.S Nationals all the
civilians all the the you know whether
you like CIA or not get all the CIA
assets out get all the assets out and
then you take big army out then you take
the guys with the guns out and the guys
with the guns all Point guns at everyone
buddy and say no you're not doing
anything and then they they all get on a
plane and leave but you don't take the
security forces out first okay it was
the major problem was tactical I agree
with you on that like I mean there's no
disagreement that the civilians come out
first but when you make a deal with the
Taliban which is the most official
government in Afghanistan we will be
gone in May which is what Donald Trump
told them in 2020 yes and then Joe Biden
comes in and drags his feet it doesn't
get the people out of there and like you
said take the military out last be out
by May that's what he should have done
yes well I I argue that if you give your
enemy uh a date I'll be out by January
1st January 1st comes and you're like
you know I'm not ready This Is War dude
yeah you wait till I leave because we
have you we are at War I mean they're
lucky they're still alive the Americans
could have nuked the entire country if
they wanted to and we well they look at
it the same way though the Taliban if
you've made a deal with them like we're
going to be gone by this time and then
you're not I mean they feel the same way
that we feel about them attacking our
guys it's like look dude you said you
were gonna be gone you're in our country
and that wasn't even your first day I
think we've given them we've kept been
jerking their chain for forever I
believe you know setting state after day
after day there's at least multiple
other ones from what I recollect I'm not
as good it just ended up being like uh I
think it was actually September 1st when
we left it ended up being I'm all about
the horrendous why we're even there in
the first place it's insane get out as
soon as possible but it wasn't done
right no no disagree I think it would
have been a crap show either way to be
honest I mean don't be wrong I think
there's definitely probably room to say
you know could have been handled better
maybe Trump's plan was better I don't
know but at the end of the day like I
don't think like let's be real the
taliban's the Taliban and we didn't
really have anything set in place no
would we ever have something in place to
to resist this so it was going to be a
crap show no matter what it's just a
matter to what degree now I think like I
think the military I think the military
knows that there is a proper way to
withdraw forces from a hostile area I
think the military like they're I think
they're better ways probably yes well
yeah I mean I mean I don't think there's
going to be any situation that ends up
looking good you know well I mean I
don't know but you I don't know I think
that they they probably could have kept
I think they probably could have kept
things it's gonna come down a little bit
but I mean like you don't need bombs
going off and you don't need to take
your security Force out before you get
your your you also had Trump's generals
lying to him about the status of how
things were in those countries you know
you have a train wreck yeah I was saying
this the other night with the members of
Congress if we were able to get another
Trump term without the weights on his
legs with Russia gate and the other lies
and the manipulation of the nonsense I
think things would be would go
swimmingly it would be it would be
amazing what we would see I genuinely
believe Trump wanted a side of these
foreign Wars I genuinely believe he
wanted us to have no involvement as
World Police I I genuinely believe he
wants to secure our borders bring
factories back and start improving these
things you know I think like you guys
were saying he's a 90s Democrat or
whatever yeah but what you get with that
with him is
russiagate investigations lies
manipulations Ukraine gate impeachment
Scandal and so even with all of that
I've heard from so many people back in
2019 about how it was the best year of
their lives in terms of making money and
and seeing their companies grow and
getting better jobs now we have Joe
Biden and everything's just bad I mean
it's bad we the the I talk about this
local race track the horse track they
want to reopen the restaurant so you can
hang out have a burger and watch the
horses run that sounds like an awesome
time but they can't find any workers we
we tried getting people to come out here
and do work on our HVAC and they just
ghost us it's crazy how how messed up it
is right now I wonder I wonder if you
guys listening at home are experiencing
similar things where like people just
don't want to work
and I I think what we were saying we
were hearing the other day from Byron
Donald's is that with the stimulus
package and the money that was being
given out pushed largely by democrats
you get demand at high but supply low
because nobody is working to produce
anything it's going to drive prices way
up oh yeah no disagreement there and
this isn't to excuse any of Biden's
policies Biden's policies have a hundred
percent made things way worse but we
were already living in a bubble when you
know after the 2008 crash you know
things started building up and then we
were living on low interest rates things
were artificially you know more popping
than they should have been there was
going to be something that pricked the
bubble eventually if I were Donald Trump
I personally wouldn't have wanted to get
reelected in the end of 2020 I would
have read the writing on the wall then
like things are going to suck next year
and the year after regardless of who the
president is definitely made things
worse but yeah it's the boom bus cycle
it's just we print a bunch of money the
money gets artificially inflated seems
to be a better deal than it is and we
convince ourselves that's great and so
we keep on doing it keep on doing until
eventually the floor falls out
oh that's the vibe I hit with Jim Cramer
when he there's a quote where he was
like is the best year of Our Lives or
the best you know but I think what
happened is the the inflation balloon
had expanded to its capacity so it's
like this is the biggest the balloon has
ever been guys I don't I don't think
that the bubbles popped I mean like I
believe
yeah the air is coming out fast but I
don't I'm like it's like if you if
you're of the opinion that the the you
know the economy was overheated and they
printed too much money and things you
know are gonna get bad if you're of the
of that opinion things have not even
come close to how bad they're going to
correct because you're because the the
the bubble in the dollar has not gone
away me and serge were actually talking
about this before uh it was funny in the
the before show whatever thing he does
um actually my buddy Clint uh Clint uh
Clint Russell we we talked about this
before and he has a theory that he
thinks likely probably the next 10 years
that China will probably collapse
monetarily in some form now that'll
likely cause some sort of deflation area
pressure which will then boost us back
up and so then we get that juice that
like you know where everything's great
it's awesome but it's like China China
is because you know the way they the way
they expand how we expand we expand
militarily they expand with money uh
because they're far more Communists and
they've you know it exponential over
time it's building up so I mean it's
just a matter of it's the same idea with
the boom bust cycle over here but to a
greater degree so it's just a matter of
when does this pop I don't know I would
say likely I mean I don't know could
somehow it could be papered over
something else could happen but let's
say their money did bust that would
cause a deflationary pressure over here
to where we kind of sort of get sucked
back into a boom and if that happens
then what happens when we convince
ourself we're great all over again and
we're like oh no problem just keep on
going like we do and then the floor
comes again later and it's even lower
maybe uh I mean if that's the case then
you you're essentially everyone's got a
little bit of time to prepare or a
little more time yeah that's better but
you got to be mindful and look at from a
bigger picture so you understand that
you can still move to New Hampshire it's
not too late yeah so like are you saying
the US was spread out militarily kind of
like the British Empire with India for
instance and then India had a revolution
and Britain lost all that Revenue coming
out of India so would it be a Chinese
economic Revolution or like Chinese
companies are in Afghanistan but one day
those people will be like actually we
live here I just mean they're doing
they're inflating their money at a
higher uh how do I put this at a higher
rate than we are so they are they're
going like this whereas we're going like
this so they're more likely they're
going to Boom at some or Bust at some
point like this the money is not sound
with what they're doing like they you
can't just print money forever
eventually goes down that's why they
have whole ghost cities and stuff yeah
yeah I mean it's not just their money of
us also their architecture and
everything like if you look at the ghost
cities like he's talking they have the
homeless problem but they also have
these giant cities that nobody lives in
it's almost like communism is a bad form
of Economics I know they're a mixed
they're sort of like a mixed thing I
guess you know when World military
superpowers start to go bankrupt they
tend to look outside of their borders
for resources like the Nazis uh the
Germans when they were destroyed after
World War one they almost had you could
argue no choice but to invade foreign
countries for to repopulate or repurpose
like if they lose their pipelines but
with the Petro dollar we don't have to
worry about it the way past Empires had
to because people are forced to use our
currency to buy things so we just we
don't got to do anything we just point
guns and then say use our money or else
we just gotta Aid in a genocide in Yemen
so the Saudis will keep you know
printing dollars uh printing oil and
dollars Peter zeihan are you guys
familiar with his has pronounced his
last name he's brilliant guy who was on
Rogan a few weeks ago on Rogan that's so
funny of riding on his shoulders um but
he said that China would be gone in five
years I don't know what exactly he meant
yeah and and that we'd be it was almost
like I'm not hopeful I don't know what
to think about that because like I mean
the Soviet Union dissipated relatively
peacefully yeah they they broke up I
don't know that I'm not sure it was
relatively peacefully I mean there was
there was a lot of turmoil in preferable
just for how big it is it's preferable
to like an international War but I think
if you go to like the former Soviet
states that are no longer Soviet States
the 90s were real rough there's still
people in the Soviet in Russia that long
for the days of the Soviet Union because
they remember the 90s and it's the 90s
were really really really hard in
Eastern Europe and and the former Soviet
States and they don't look at Freedom
the way that we do because freedom for
them was full of corruption and a lot of
bad people that had influence in the in
the the the state before just started
taking things and saying well me and my
boys with the guns now own this Refinery
or whatever so it wasn't so peacefully
it just we didn't see the effects here
in the U.S of the break of the Soviet
Union so so clearly let's jump to this
next topic we got some Tim Cassidy big
news everybody I know our libertarian
guests are really excited to hear meta
has reinstated Trump's Facebook and
Instagram with heightened penalties
other public figures with accounts are
reinstated from suspensions related to
civil unrest will also face similar
penalties but there it is everybody Maga
man is back Donald Trump can now post on
Facebook and Instagram and he should and
he should also be on Twitter
I don't know man I think I think he's
got a contract with truth social that
says he can't for a certain period of
time or something like that because I
want to be clear Trump his social media
presence was by far my favorite thing
about him like he was I loved his
Twitter I loved how he talked about it
you don't say Reed you don't say I might
have taken you're kidding right
it's kind of like Tim was bringing up
earlier with a if he hadn't had his like
weights and don't I'm not saying he's a
perfect guy I'm not saying he's like Ron
Paul or something but if he did if
government does a perfect guy yeah well
not perfect but he's the closest idea of
a politician I can think of but if he
wasn't weighed down if the government
didn't government it'd be super awesome
yes the incentives point a certain way
and like it was if you like for example
I think if like a Ron Paul got in office
I think it would probably be a similar
thing either he'd take a ride down in
Dallas or he would end up you know some
way being tied down this way or that to
where he wasn't really able to get the
things he'd done what he wanted done the
same way Trump was because there's
certain incentives in place when you
start rocking the boat it doesn't work
out well usually yeah you got to have
the American population rock the boat
for you and then you just make sure that
you don't veto their changes when they
rock it to where it needs to be rocked
to uh but if you go up there and try to
become the president make all the
changes yourself you're just an easy
target
I mean I honestly don't have any faith
at all like the in politics in general
but especially at a federal level I
think once you get down more local you
get more to where you can actually have
uh results even down to the individual I
think as an individual you can make your
life better more than you can fix the
federal government you you don't think
Trump is perfect no have you not seen
his body when he's golfing it's true
very bigly he might be the most healthy
president ever too too healthy the
healthiest too healthy yeah he had to
get he had to he had to slow down fatten
up for the role I do miss him I mean I'm
glad that like we're starting to see him
more um and I mean I I I just loved the
comedic value he brought to everything
it was so much fun he initiated clown
world I'm really much fun I want to meet
him because I'm tired of talking about
him like a third person Donald come on
the show and what doesn't he not own
truth social so how could he did he sign
you guys got to get uh my friend Eric
Jackman on here he does the perfect
Trump impersonations you got to check
check out Jackman radio on Twitter
oh God Trump has seen him act as himself
and he approved of it he had him come up
on stage and congratulated him and
everything Phil's seen it it's great
it's a good it's a good trip he's losing
weight though he's been getting in shape
so good on you buddy but he's trying to
emulate Trump's perfect health so
awesome
so Tim you were saying even as an owner
of a company yeah you can have contract
with yourself so I mean I don't think he
owns true social 100 I think they're a
SPAC so they have shareholders and stuff
like that and then in order to do this
deal if if people are gonna buy shares
of this company they need to know that
Trump's can abandon it so the company
says to increase his own valuation he
made a deal that he wouldn't leave he
would but it's not just him there's
other people involved in the company who
say if we're going to do this if we're
going to work a company with you you got
to agree not to go to other platforms so
my understanding is that he can post on
truth and then he can link to his truth
post ah so he can post on Twitter or
something like I called that fat pig out
and then linked to truth and then truth
shows the bigger one only Rosie
O'Donnell and there's like a time frame
too he can post it on truth and a
certain amount of time he can then post
it on Twitter or someone somewhere else
but he's got to get back on these
platforms man so didn't Elon say he was
gonna like out he wasn't gonna allow
just nothing but posting to another
platform wasn't there something he said
about I think he walked that back okay
and and the funny thing is everyone got
really mad at him about that but that's
literally the policy of every social
media platform if you use the platform
just to link out to a different platform
you can get suspended or get your your
post removed YouTube especially they'll
ban you out right
because people would do this thing where
they'd make a live stream saying go
watch the show on Twitch instead and
then YouTube's like nah you can't do
that delete so Elon says we'll do the
same thing if you're only linking out to
somebody else we're gonna you know you
can't do that everybody got mad and it's
Twitter's a different platform you know
so um truth social is owned by Trump
media and Technology Group which is
owned by Donald Trump as far as I can
tell and Devin Nunez is the CEO of the
parent company but that parent company
Trump media and Technology Group merged
with a company called Digital World
acquisition core in 2021 October I don't
know who owns digital world yeah dwac
yeah I don't know who owns that exactly
but I'm about to find out I love how
like instead of tweets they're literally
called truths isn't that every time it's
so weird I don't like the brand you
don't it's not a verb I know but it's so
Trump it's so trumpy I just love it
truth is subjective like so is Trump
that like that spaceship on the table is
pointing to the left but for you that
spaceship on the table is pointing to
the right easy so we're post-modernism
both of our truths are correct like
literally that that spaceship model you
see right in front of you it's pointing
to the left but to you that's not true
it depends yeah so our perspective is
guiding Our Truth so I I don't like that
he's claiming that he has the truth I
don't disagree with your the concept
you're drawing but it's Trump so I just
love it that he every time he says
something it's a truth you know it's
just very it's very much the way he
thinks so yeah he's true thing that's
all that's the only thing he ever does
everything is a truth but we in a Mac we
need him back I don't know I don't know
why he's not he's not posting maybe it's
contractual obligations I have a feeling
he's just not in touch with the bass
anymore so Tim do you think he would win
because I've been amazed how many people
don't think he would win now yeah I'm
not entirely sure I mean I see the
propaganda where they claim that Joe
Biden would beat him by eight points but
I just roll my eyes at that I'm not sure
it matters if it's Trump or ham sandwich
so long as ballot harvesting and
Universal mail and voting is the is the
Machine by which we're determining our
elections in 2016 he was a wrench in the
in the spokes of the transition of the
liberal world order to the New World
Order like he got us out of
trans-pacific partnership day one and
they without him even knowing what he
was doing probably he was smashing up
the plan and they wanted him out but now
I think the plan is out in the open and
it's like kind of amorphous we're
obviously not going techno communist no
one I don't know anyone that's down to
put microchips and be spied on all day
by a corporation and be told when and
what you can say yeah uh so let's I
think maybe there's a lot more potential
for him but he's older I mean Congress
want that Gates they were they really
are are bullish on Trump I just don't
think he's in touch with his base yeah
the whole back stuff and then this was
definitely yours thanks I'll pass off to
you but just I don't I just I don't like
I mean I'm not a republican but most
people I hang out with those are like
the I feel like that's the base that he
had the kind of people I interact with
on daily day-to-day thing they're all
like DeSantis you know that's what
they're all about that's what everyone's
about these days so unless he changes
his messaging maybe gets on Twitter gets
rails things back up again maybe I don't
know I don't see it right now but the
law can change between now and then gets
like a really young famous energetic
vice president that could save a lot of
life I mean he needs to get back into
the public space he's been putting out
these videos where he talks about his
policy plans and he's very much been
addressing culture War issues but he
needs to just get on Twitter and that's
a tough thing you know Elon Musk buys
Twitter I'm sure Elon is like please
Trump come back because it's gonna it's
gonna set the platform on fire in like
in a good way it's going to light it up
Trump's got to get out there and post
those those tweets where he calls Coke
garbage yeah remember that one I'll
still keep drinking that garbage though
that's that's that's that's what we want
to see he needs to be Trump trump needs
to be Trump on Twitter he needs to be he
needs to be trumped in the in the domain
where people are going to see him most
and he needs to be the off the cuff
Trump when I speak of my haters I speak
of them with love it's not their father
born after
I love it not having Twitter you are
invisible like even at my level I I just
got my Twitter back this morning I lost
it in October of 2021 and without it
like it's hard to network with people
and the same with his level at the level
he is it's hard to be in touch with the
world because Twitter is how politics
travels now yeah it's you become
invisible in the political space yeah
not necessarily in the entire
entertainment Zone sure I don't know if
I mean Mr Beast has a Twitter profile
but I mean it's all YouTube you know
once you get big on YouTube for cartoons
and making people laugh you don't really
need Twitter it's just like uh but if
you're in politics you absolutely need
to be connected to that I think to
understand
um I don't know man I wish I knew if he
was on contract exclusive through social
contract because where the hell is he
well outside of that there's a
conversation about how do we protect our
rights on social media if what you're
saying is true you can't Network without
Twitter it's it's very difficult a
technology is being granted to one
political faction to use you know
however they see fit another faction is
getting is getting banned and suspended
how do you solve for that I mean I don't
think you guys are going to be all about
government regulation in that regard
yeah what's crazy is you know you guys
had Jeremy Kaufman on last year I think
who's a friend of mine New Hampshire he
created
Odyssey which was like a free speech
alternative to YouTube and the feds have
been going after him like crazy there's
been all sorts of court cases uh right
now Ben Swann who I have networked with
a little bit he's trying to create a new
platform called Sovereign and all these
different platforms are just learning
from the mistakes of the previous ones
where the federal government can
basically screw them over and trying to
figure out how to work their way around
it but I think that is the alternative
is like making all just making
alternatives on the point we're talking
about with Trump earlier like his feet
being made up same thing with this like
if you're trying to you know create
different ways for this to work use when
we saw with Twitter and it's pretty
clear with Facebook and probably other
social medias well they're infiltrated
with FEDS they they get you know
corporate welfare this that but the
little guys like Odyssey all these other
op starts they are have the exact
opposite problems the incentives are
driving things one way or the other so
it's like I don't really necessarily I
think throwing the government and next
is going to help if anything I think
reducing it would be the best personally
but I mean I don't know it is usually
people do get a brand name that's what
they stick with but definitely don't let
them get infiltrated with FEDS like
Twitter did
I don't know that you can can prevent uh
you know social media companies from
becoming infiltrated with uh you know
with Federal Building
the reason I say is because it's too too
much of a Honeypot I mean the the the
capabilities that your average phone has
like to monitor the average person uh
the the idea that the federal government
isn't going to attempt to get their
fingers into into software that makes
that possible I don't know that that you
you get a world without governments
trying to do that and I don't know how
you stopped them well you free software
if your code's on GitHub or gitlab or
something where people can watch and see
if it's tracking you at least you know
if it's the software itself is tracking
you the networks are I don't know you'll
never be able to keep people out of the
networks you'll have feds undercover in
the networks but you don't want it's the
comp you don't want companies running
social media I don't I the companies can
get hijacked so you want decentralized
software packets to do it on if they
drop the patents it'd be like maybe
that's another thing where the
government gets involved with the patent
system I'm sure I mean I'm not a tech
guy I'm kind of a tech idiot but if they
dial back some of that some of the
regulation they have there like it makes
so much easier for those for a starting
point for people for like alternative
like social medias and stuff exactly oh
like uh patents because I know your big
thing is about like you're releasing
information in the world like uh I mean
I'm I don't know exactly how it works
Tech I'm a tech idiot but I'm assuming a
lot of these things are protected
between like IP type stuff yes yes so
and I know that's a common point you
touch on a lot yeah I brought that up
last night too Jim Jordan that one way
instead of breaking up a company
Monopoly like Twitter or or Alphabet by
Smashing it into seven different
companies and then giving the CEO of
alphabet access to all the code from all
seven companies which it would be
counter productive counterintuitive you
would actually force them to free their
software code or aspects of their
software code that would let other
people compete I would be completely
miserable if that happened to Apple and
the reason is I want Apple to have tight
control over their products because I am
willing to pay extra for the Synergy
that comes when you use Apple products
when I open up my my uh my earpods for
the first time they automatically find
the phone Etc like Apple products are
made to work together as soon as you
open up the code and you you essentially
are just turning Apple products into
other Hardware where the where the
software is is open and people can can
do whatever they want to create software
then you end up with the same issue that
you get with PCS now which is you don't
know how reliable the company that
produced whatever piece of software you
have is or whatever whatever piece of
software you want to use you know how
reliable are they are you don't know how
the quality control is you don't know
what that piece of software is going to
do to other software in your computer I
stick with apple stuff because I know
that Apple controls it and apple
controls it tightly and I know that this
is probably an unpopular opinion for a
lot of people but you're on a one yeah
it's because when they can I don't but I
don't want people I don't want people
getting into apple and saying well you
have to do this and making apple stuff
work
uh taking away the Synergy that Apple's
products have I like the way Apple
products work and I don't want some
government person getting involved in
saying Apple's too big has too much
control so we want to stick our nose in
and say that you have to do this and
have to do that there's two aspects of
like when you're building software is um
compatibility like ease of ease of use
and then a security is one of them Apple
is very low security we don't know what
their security systems are doing if
they're tracking you if they're selling
your DNA they told the FBI to pound sand
when they were trying to get that Terror
the dude they were accused of terrorists
they wanted to unlock his phone the and
Apple's like yo we're not doing it
because you'd have to make a back end
into the thing so granted you can't
predict the future but I was happy with
that result that they told the FBI to go
f off you know so Apple's a big no for
me dog
just I'm not I'm again we we had you
know we got an one apple machine here
out of all the machines because we had
someone who was like well I know to use
apple and it's just been a disaster I I
was like the integration is the opposite
of what you're describing yes for apple
with using other IBM stuff but if you're
no like you can't even like hard drives
for instance it's like we want to
transfer data between hard drives you
could take a hard drive between any any
PC but not between apple yeah but like
apple is one company versus the eight
million other companies that's part of
why I don't want them to mess with apple
because there's all these other options
yeah but then the hard drive would work
between other computers so instead it's
like we plugged the hard drive and it's
like there's no data on it and we're
like well it can work in literally any
of the various PCS from different brands
different companies different laptops
but not the Apple yeah that one we have
weird problems with they're finally
adopting USBC I think they kept building
their own plugs and like they have to uh
I think Europe passed a law saying they
have to use a standard so it's going to
be USBC I was deep on um free software
last night thinking about like so what
so I started to think about the arms
manufacturers I'm like okay liberal
economic order is basically Lockheed
Martin Boeing uh there's five of them
Raytheon
uh Northrop Grumman and General Dynamics
but then there's the British one Bae
system so the six of them together
comprise about 140 billion dollars of
arms dealers five of the six largest
arms dealers on Earth are in America
they are supplying us directly with our
own weapons and I was like would I force
them to free their software code
arguably hell no because and how would I
do that because then you're giving your
weapon systems to the potential enemy I
don't like thinking in terms of friend
and enemy but they do the weapons
manufacturers sure are I'm like can't we
just blow up bombs on Mars to heat it up
we don't know these are actual tactical
games they're playing with weapons they
want to fight that's what this system
they seem to want to so what I'm sorry
no good I feel like so I think there are
times that you don't want to open source
of code but when it comes to social
media and information I am bullish
no I just I think that that uh nowadays
the the chips and most of your
microchips and stuff are not made in the
US and there's a strong likelihood that
they're all compromised anyways with
words they're made in China or Taiwan or
whatever we're gonna uh
we're gonna dive head first into the
shallow end with this next story about
Eliza blue Chrissy Mayer and uh all the
stuff that's been gone over the past
week and uh we'll just uh we'll be as
candid as possible I'm sure we'll piss
some people off but we have this tweet
from Chrissy Mayer for those that aren't
familiar Christian Mayer is a comedian
and she hosts a podcast called simpcast
and she's been on the show I think I
think a couple times right it's been a
couple times we've had on the show
before and so there's been some
controversy related to a guest we had
recently Eliza blue and some censorship
actions that she's been accused of
notably filing privacy requests against
people who talk about her past work and
so here we have the story from Chrissy
Mayer she says Eliza blue got four of my
YouTube videos removed for showing a
fair and balanced dock trailer which
featured three to five seconds of her
public at the time now removed World
Star Hip-Hop video must be nice to have
the power to rewrite history then
Gaslight Twitter and YouTube into
accepting it
now I'll say is that right
um you know I said previously I'm
uninterested in this and I'll kind of
you know I think this is this got to the
point where literally right before the
show I saw this tweet and I'm like okay
okay guys you got me all right like I'm
starting to see and learn more that's
having me question what that what what's
going on if YouTube videos getting
pulled and we're hearing that a bunch of
people actually had YouTube videos
getting pulled and so this clearly is an
abuse of the system to a degree that
we've not seen for a while now it used
to be in the early days of YouTube there
were attempts by political Rivals to to
falsely flag and get people's content
removed and now it seems like we're
seeing an uptick in this particularly
pertaining to Eliza Bloom the first
thing I'll say is as it pertains to the
issues related to me personally you know
look man um I say it a million times I'm
I'm an arrogant and so don't
don't come at me and yell it and scream
in my face and think I'm gonna bend the
knee and do anything for you and I will
tell everybody right off the bat we had
this person on the show that I don't
care too much about I don't I don't
follow her career I don't know much
about her I don't handle booking without
show two times but all of a sudden we
found ourselves inundated with and I'm
not saying you guys got to be very
careful because when I said that there
was a PR firm running like 50 accounts
everyone started claiming I called
literally the millions of people who are
watching these videos but I never said
that yeah but we started we we got some
very gruesome
um Christmas may not the right word but
let's just say you know people cross the
line with what they were sending to us
and um the images they were posting of
people easiest way to get me to be like
I will I will not give you what you want
but here's here's what I have to say
about this there are a lot of people who
are genuinely concerned about what we're
seeing in terms of what Eliza Blue's
done and her past work and there's a big
difference between those people and the
very few people I am directly
criticizing the people who are posting
just really awful photos and videos
sending awful things to us and I want to
make sure that people understand because
there's still this this you know here's
what I said earlier
following the project Veritas stuff
following you know obviously the Crowder
daily wire stuff following these
Republicans getting shot
I I'm reading this I I get I have a
source contacting me they say we want
you to read this letter check this out
and I'm like okay well we're going to
publish this and I'm reading this and
I'm like yo if if all of this bad stuff
is happening right now to various
organizations and everyone's fighting
with each other yeah that that's it like
infiltrate destroy right you you you
might be divide and conquer yeah I'm not
going to be all about that right so I'm
I set out right to to Jeremy Hamley of
the quartering look I apologize I don't
want to be fighting with you we agree on
way too much for me to be bickering or
complaining about something that is like
one issue where you know ultimately
probably agree mostly on it but there's
like a personal issue that's making you
know me upset or something like that
when I'm looking at we have another
story we'll talk about in a minute a
woman saying that she used to uh work in
in gender affirmation for children and
now she's realizing how bad it is I'm
like there's a lot more things that we
all agree on that we need to be focused
on my biggest concern with all of this
is
obviously censorship is bad but if I'm
gonna get distracted and and and you
know personally aggrieved or whatever
and that means infighting will erupt
that takes us off mission
we're being played we're being played
and so I'll say this to you right now
when I came out with my video earlier
and said exactly that like Jeremy we I
shouldn't be fighting with you I
shouldn't be com I should like that
that's not that's not what we should be
doing that's not what I should be doing
uh I so I apologize Jeremy put out a
video saying he apologizes I have
tremendous respect for that and I
sincerely apologize there are still
people trying to drum up this infighting
and and that is exactly what I'm talking
about when all this starts and I'm this
guy who's sitting here like look man I
don't know anything about her some we
booked on the show because she's on
Twitter and she's a prominent activist I
didn't know that people had beef with
her I don't know what that beef is we
get people sending us
let me just say like videos that
video photos and videos that I just
think are would would make a dad you
know like if a dad found out people were
doing about that his daughter he'd end
up in jail that kind of stuff yeah so
you wanna you wanna come at me and my
friends with these really horrifying
things and I'm gonna be like outright
not not getting anywhere near this but I
I genuinely legitimately understand
that's not most people so I hope all of
you understand that there are people
still right now trying to get us to keep
fighting I'm not going to do it I will
outright say especially upon seeing
Chrissy Mayer get get her videos taken
down I'm I'm absolutely wrong about that
I I I was personally slighted and that
gate put blinders on me I don't want to
fight with anybody I will keep being an
arrogant and I will say that
but I also recognize we shouldn't be
fighting if we can avoid it and we can
focus on things that are more important
so the only thing I didn't say just one
last thought is please keep an eye out
for those who are still in the chat
right now desperately trying to get me
to get angry and to fight with you guys
when I'm saying no wait man like we need
to come together on this yeah I think
the big thing here is people like they
say in soccer if you're a Defender keep
your eye on the ball and I think so many
people got their eye off the ball in
this story and I'm like you pointed out
with the censorship with the I mean I
don't know if you point out the legal
action she threatened supposedly online
I think those are things they're worthy
derision and worthy of looking into and
see what is going on here why is this
happening maybe there's more to the
story but this thing got taken so out of
control into such a level to things that
had nothing to do with it her past which
took me wrong like sure that like maybe
like discreditates her or something but
that I don't personally myself I
couldn't care if she made up all of that
that's not pertinent information to me
the what is pertinent to me is did she
threaten legal action against people and
is she getting accounts taken down I
don't know I'm open to it seems that way
it seems to imply I read Shane's latest
article it seems there's something
building there maybe some sort of
argument I don't know I'm still open to
and the people criticizing Tim cast for
not jumping in already they literally
had a guy there and like it was clearly
not a fleshed out story so why would you
comment on something before it's a
fleshed out story but here's here's what
I think too and I can't speak for Shane
right I will I will tell you guys with
100 sincere honesty
I told Shane I don't think the story was
worth it I don't I don't know anything
about it and I said to him if you do
this you need to sit down with Jeremy
Hambly and we need to do like two
different profiles of like what is the
big picture here
's the problem
and uh we got baited because the things
that were sent to Shane I guarantee you
like and again I can't speak from saki
said this to me but I do know that
people posted very inappropriate things
about his family
you do that you guarant that's bait they
were trying to get us to fight and so
I've now had people saying like bro it's
an up like they're trying to make you
fight each other what I was saying is
it's a PR firm that I think was trying
to promote uh Eliza because it worked in
making her famous having John Rich come
on here and be like who is the lies I'm
hearing about now and I'm like man
that's so convenient for her and I'm
specifically referring to obviously not
like a YouTube channel where they're
talking about it I'm referring to the
people even still right now in the chat
who are desperately trying to make us
fight and they're the same accounts that
spam the same things over and over and
over again clearly inorganic desperately
trying to make conflict happen sometimes
even real people get caught in that
state of mind because it's like
scratching an itch it feels so good but
if you keep scratching you're going to
rip the skin off and make it bleed like
we're in the it feels really good situ
state right now don't keep scratching uh
you know Brittany venti got her got
videos taken down of her today I made a
YouTube video for the first time in
about a month and a half today about
this on my YouTube channel Ian Crossland
please check it out after the show and
I'll remind you again and I posted a
link to Brittany's video in that video
she showed clips from this world star
music video in question this is all
revolving around this one video I think
uh that had been previously taken down
but Britney still had clips from this
now removed video on her Channel then
that video was removed over the course
of the last six hours Eliza I'm
concerned that shame is a very powerful
dangerous feeling and if you are pushed
into becoming a useful tool for cancel
culture to hyperinflate cancel culture
because of your your I know it's generic
afraid of your past but just
it's don't become the villain that
you're looking to
squash out that's the best advice I
think I can give you right now but if
these bands are unjust they need to be
rectified if something Britney said in
her video she's showing screenshots of
Twitter's ban thing and they said that
it was Private privately privately
created or distributed sensitive content
as a Twitter role it was publicly
distributed sensitive content it was not
private and it was taken down for it
being a privately sensitive piece of
content how sensitive is it really it
was the music video yeah she made the
video she she was proud of it she was
you know uh ostensibly she was was
spreading it around back in the day so I
think that's Up For Debate but I think
it for the sake of argument we'd say it
is it is sensitive content but it was
public sensitive content so Twitter
reinstate Brittany that ban is unjust in
my opinion simply put in just to go back
to like our position on this I think I
got tricked I think I think we all got
tricked here into taking out our anger
on people like Jeremy and Brittany I
think so I was like uh I don't want to
get into too much detail about what was
happening to us but like
you know these are my friends and people
I care about and I don't want to call
them threats or anything but the stuff
we were getting sent was let's just put
like put it triggering if someone sent
you the stuff that we got sent you'd
probably react the same way and then
when you know I was looking at I I made
this joke tweet earlier I was like daily
wire project Veritas me and the
quartering it's all you thought it was a
coincidence wait till phase two or
whatever like as a joke people thought
it was real and then I stopped and kind
of thought about it when I was reading
the Veritas letter and I'm like people
were saying is it a coincidence that
right after the Pfizer thing comes out
you know we have the Grammys brought to
you by Pfizer we do this big thing
complaining about it all of a sudden
we're getting slammed with these people
claiming to represent a group of people
but they're sending us some of the most
abhorrent and awful things you could
imagine pissing us off and making us
fight and then I'm just like yo nah I'm
not doing it you're not you got me you
you got me for a few days but I'm not
gonna do it now and to some of the
nicest people I've ever met the two
people in question I've interacted with
them met one of them personally and like
even with the limit time I know that
generally are some of the nicest people
ever who are you talking about uh the
one person because I'm sure we don't
want to name name the name to deflate it
no oh I don't care then and then Shane
Cashman so uh Shane met I've only met
him online uh done one show with him you
came on my show for ponyboys which is a
joking ripoff of Four Horsemen uh
because we're buddies and so who cares
uh but yeah I found my show he's like
the nice guy ever met and the super
interesting fella and just for this to
happen to someone like that now that it
makes it better who they are but it's
just disgusting this is this is the
thing too it's like
even before we did anything we were
getting sent awful stuff and getting
attacked and then so I was like okay
well we're going to cover this and then
it ramped up and got crazier and then of
course I'm like I got an internal
conversation with Shane and I'm saying
like I don't know if we can handle
whatever the this is or what they're
doing and he's like oh we got to tell
the story man you know what's something
I realized I I recommended well so I
mean Shane's clearly pissed I don't know
I think we talked to him the plan now is
maybe as soon as possible is to have
Chrissy mayor on with Shane and then
just hash all this stuff out because I
think we're being played I love that
Britney ventian Eliza on at some point
in the future after we work through
these Cycles I think it's fantastic this
is this is this kind of thing we can
avoid in the future if we talk about it
now you know I realized we have a
responsibility to talk about this stuff
it's not stuff I want to do I don't want
to get dramatic and talk about my
friends online I don't know who did what
who said what but when it comes to
Banning and people losing their
livelihoods like if someone's banned
from Twitter that's their that could be
their life their their income and it's
are this show Tim me we we have a
responsibility to talk about cancel
culture and social media censorship I
don't it's it's just like you know with
great power comes great responsibility
and you have to make personal sacrifices
the sacrifice we have to make we have to
talk about this stuff
I think that it's pretty clear that I
don't imagine that people thought that
the the Tim cast brand was
pro-censorship uh because of this stuff
um but I mean there there's a lot of
people in the chat that are like you
said that are still looking to Stir It
Up that are that are you know a lot of
issues so like that was that was the
thing about it is I'm seeing people post
videos being like you know I'm canceling
my membership at timcast.com and stuff
like that and we gained over a thousand
members in the past in the past week
which is three times like what we
normally do I think everybody involved
in this has become more famous as a
result of this whole thing no I think
you could call it infighting Stephen
Crowder is way more popular than he was
two months ago daily wire a lot more
people heard daily wire when I saw that
Meme of you with Jack Murphy's beard on
your face I was like people that you've
never heard of now that don't even
aren't in politics are hearing about you
yeah but that's it's not a good thing
when we're arguing with each other about
this instead of talking about this next
story what you need to see it can be a
good thing if we if we make it right no
I don't like infighting I don't like I
don't like that as some as a means to
generate notoriety like if we're gonna
if we're gonna uh if you want drama
let's have drama with this take a look
at the story from from the Free Press
I thought I was saving trans kids now
I'm blowing the whistle there are more
than 100 pediatric gender clinics across
the U.S I worked at one what's happening
to Children is morally and medically
appalling I mean that's the gist of her
story it's a woman who worked for four
years at a clinic as a case manager
responsible for patient intake and
oversight I left the clinic in November
last year because I could no longer
participate in what was happening there
by the time I I departed I was certain
that the way the American Medical system
is treating these patients is the
opposite of the promise to do no harm
instead we are permanently harming the
vulnerable patients in our care the I
I'm segwaying here but I want to mention
this is the kind of story that makes me
be like guys you know what man I will I
will eat Humble Pie I will do whatever I
I need your help on this one I don't
want to fight with people about about
drama stuff we shouldn't do that I
shouldn't do that I'll do I'll say
whatever I have to say to to calm
everybody out to chill to chill
everybody out
and that's on me I'll take that because
this is the kind of stuff that makes me
feel like
look look
I've been talking on this channel for a
long time about just getting the van
down by the river and just letting it
all go away and the problem with that is
every time I imagine how how much more
fun in a sense my life would be if I
just said I'm done working 16 hour days
I'm done running a company I'm gonna go
hang out by the river and just catch
some fish and just breathe the fresh air
and then I think about five years after
that
people will be locked up in camps kids
will be getting castrated money will be
worthless and I'm like yeah if we stop
doing what we're doing or if we turn on
each other
this is the kind of stuff that doesn't
get exposed I believe this woman who's
coming out here is coming out now and
saying hey what they're doing to kids is
wrong is likely doing it not completely
because of the work that we do or people
like like the quartering or whatever but
partially as a grain of sand making that
Heap the more we promote individuals
calling this out the more people will
wake up to what the cult is yeah and if
we do nothing and if we fight with each
other and I'll take responsibility on
that if I keep doing that if I keep
getting pissed off and telling people to
go screw themselves I'm going to wake up
one day in a world where this is the
norm 100 I just spent the past week in
La working with you know doing ATR stuff
and I know a lot of the very
left-leaning people and and you know
spending time in Los Angeles and
Hollywood and stuff those are the kind
of people that you run into and
even people that you would consider
left-leaning they have kids and they
hear about this kind of stuff and
they're just like yo no this is this is
where I draw the line and they don't
want to talk about it in public they
don't want to admit it because it's you
know it's a dangerous thing to to be
just to condemn this kind of stuff
because there's all kinds of
associations that people on the left
make if you condemn this this some these
kind of gender surgeries
um gender assignment synergies
um but parents are over it parents don't
want it doesn't matter if they're left
or right parents are are strongly of the
opinion that this stuff is bad and
without people like this show like the
people that we have on here pushing back
on this stuff people don't come out and
say hey this stuff is bad they don't
have the the intestinal fortitude or
whatever to stand up and say hey no I'm
I really have this uh this this of this
this problem with these procedures and
stuff so it is important Matt Walsh went
down County and he spoke about critical
race Theory and gender ideology in these
schools it is this kind of work where
look man I don't agree with Matt Walsh
on a lot of things all right he's a he's
a bold guy to put it mildly but I think
you know in in
in a future where there is factions of
Matt Walsh's the disagreements we have
is sitting at a table and him being like
look Tim I just don't agree with you on
on how we're going to be implementing a
policy like that and then me saying
things like well look I don't know but
you know I'll see The Ballot Box whereas
today it's people
bringing kids in for castration you know
what I mean I wonder about you guys you
know Jose and Reed like I think of you
guys as the Pinnacle of libertarianism
and I wonder how do you deal with this
kind of clip that it's about what's this
about when you live about that I don't
know if you would call libertarian hands
off but when you live like you live your
life I'll live mine how do you what do
you do when a parent across the road
wants to cut their kids genitals off and
turn them into another gender yeah so
I'm all about cultural repulsion
basically I think that's the strongest
the strongest way to go like in New
Hampshire uh we're really trying to
create a culture of obnoxious Liberty as
Phil can attest to not just the Twitter
account but just in general
snowmen up in New Hampshire the only
reason this has taken off is because the
cultural sensibility is allowing it to
go on and handling these people with kid
gloves if we push back and said oh yeah
it's ridiculous that you want to uh you
know mess with the endocrine system of a
young child at a point where their
endocrine system is already in flux and
mutilate their genitals in a point where
they're not really in any sort of stage
to give any sort of meaningful consent
in their life yeah I don't think it's
that crazy but like hey yeah you're not
like to be essentially a bully to to
push back culturally the opposite way
and I mean I'm not saying do violence to
these people or anything like that but
there's no reason you need to accept
that as a narrative because that's okay
there are people constantly saying that
they're so glad that they left New
Hampshire because it's such a
Libertarian idiots or whatever and we're
all like good we're glad you left and
they I mean they have protests where
they're calling free Staters Vermin
invasive species that need to be
exterminated that's what they're saying
about us this is because you guys troll
people yeah because we're so obnoxious
and by the way to be clear I'm not
saying to do that to adults who have
made this choice on their own I mean I
have my personal opinions it's probably
a little bit ridiculous if you start
like you know but like snip snip but you
know so far it's your life at that point
do what you want I don't care Dave Smith
made a great point when he said that
stigma is how you peacefully discourage
uh behavior that you don't like and so
the idea that libertarianism equals
libertine uh government we bully them a
lot yeah Libertines what's that well so
just because something is legal doesn't
mean that you have to endorse it and
that's one of the things that people
that have it you know you call them
state or we call them status or whatever
but like that's what a status tends to
think if you say I don't think this
should be illegal they automatically in
their brain jump to the conclusion that
you endorse the behavior and so I don't
think that it should be illegal for
people to get uh you know to get gender
reassignment surgery that's fine you
know you live your life go ahead you
know that's that's totally fine but
there's nothing wrong with stigmatizing
people that want to have children or
young adults get gender reassignment
surgery and condemning the idea of
teenagers and and or children getting
gender reassigner surgery that's
something that Society should do there
are there are challenges to any kind of
like like the idea of cosmetic surgery
is is a gradient it's not yes or no it's
not black or white so if we would we
could ask a few questions to explore the
morality of uh transgender surgeries and
plastic surgery in general is it okay
for an 18 year old human being to have
their hand Surgical removed
tin I say I mean because of the fact
that you have to have an arbitrary line
I guess 18 but then you're not fully
developed yeah well I mean I'm a legal
adult yeah you you think it's okay do
you would you guys I mean I don't wanna
conversation
those three words it should be legal but
it should be condemned like people
shouldn't support the idea people
shouldn't encourage it and doctors
shouldn't say let's go ahead and cut
your hand off like we I mean it should I
don't think that we should have what do
you guys think I agree should it be
illegal for adults to have their hands a
hand surgically removed I think the
ethical thing for a doctor is to not do
it because and I think you know stigma
comes in play if they do do it they get
shunned upon by the doctors Community
other people in the community
Etc this is where the Ron Paul argument
about heroin comes in he he told a bunch
of Republicans and what was that 2012 in
South Carolina like if heroin was legal
today how many of you would go shoot up
right now and the whole crowd was like
yeah none of us would I mean No One's
Gonna like cut off their hand you know I
mean they will yeah it's called General
General body dysmorphic disorder
something that effect where people they
feel like they're I talked about this
with uh the Twitter 1.0 Executives when
they were when they were talking about
how they got to protect trans people
because they're having an identity
identity crisis that results in
depression and potentially suicide I
said the same is true for General body
dysmorphia anorexic for instance people
are starving themselves to death or
people who overeat and become morbidly
obese and have heart attacks but also
people who want to have their limbs
removed and they do there are many
stories of uh there's one guy who had
like a tree fall on his arm so that he
could justify amputation because he
wanted it removed from his body so cut
it down on top of his arm something like
that happened yeah he had it fall in his
arms that he could justify removing it
or something that effect or I think he
smashed with a hammer and then claimed
something like that happened and he
needed to get it removed there are
people who are experiencing this and
there are questions about what is the
best way to provide assistance to them
if there is no you know and this is
where I suppose I'm more liberal and
less libertarian
if the Opera if the law exists you could
shun a guy all day and night but if he's
getting paid the money for it you didn't
care what you think well here's the
thing like I'm I've been a blue collar
worker for the last 10 years of my life
and every time some anomaly takes place
OSHA thinks they have to regulate it
away from ever happening again instead
of accepting people are stupid and
they're gonna make mistakes and dumb
stuff is going to happen and having a
very you know reasonable set of
guidelines they make it so now you have
to wear a harness when you're four feet
in the air
so I'm just saying that like
justifying a law because of red herrings
just leads you to a place of stupidity
it's I don't think it's a red herring
because those are those are things that
actually happen like they're actually
the question about the hand removing the
hand is a question of can you pay a
doctor to remove a healthy body part and
the answer right now is for the most
part yes that's not how you actually
help a person who's suffering from
somebody dysmorphia you so what happens
is hey man you if the money is going
good but if someone is I'll put it I'll
put it this way because it doesn't
include death uh what we often talk
about is the Golden Gate Bridge and
every person who's jumped off it and
survived has explained that the one they
immediately regretted it and the one
thing going through their mind was all
of life's problems could be solved
except for having jumped off the bridge
and so if they jump off and they end up
regretting it and they live we learn
that if someone says I need my hand
removed and then they regret it what do
we do it's it's you never get back and
you had that one Doctor Who said uh that
woman who said of children who get
mastectomies if they ever want if they
want breasts when they're older they can
just get implants like that's not the
same thing you've lost them this is
where stigma comes in uh a good example
I have a business I I breed hairless
cats I know it sounds silly but we we
deal with clients we sell them and this
is where stigma comes in yes sir you
could have the concept of hey uh you
know the money's good that's it but we
even have turned down business many
times because we're like I don't like
this client I don't like the idea that
this person is going to have my my pet
and they're going to be a representation
of my brand and and vice versa like we
also have to upkeep a certain standard
have a clean cat room a nice presenting
house because we want to have a good
looking brand because we don't want to
be looked at as like crap so like the
idea that uh and I'm not trying to like
crap on you or anything but I'm just
saying like the idea that's just like oh
as long as the money's good there's a
whole lot more that goes into that and
yes on an individual level there still
will be like in our there's definitely
people that go so hairless catch like
500 bucks which is like criminally low
for them and it's just gross like and
those are going to exist but in the long
run that is not a good way to upkeep
what you're doing because it's just it
doesn't work like but there will be
individual situations that system works
best obviously in a system where it's
culturally homogeneous you're right we
don't need government but that's not
what we have and that's not what's
happening around the world and I think
it's it's an idealistic answer to be
like well you know someone shouldn't cut
off a person's hand but they'll be
shunned for it they'll go set up a
practice in the middle of nowhere and
they'll do it yeah I think shunning
works on local levels when you know
people like you have a small business
you know technically um but when you
have like large multinational
corporations that are for-profit you
know medicating people for life we cut
your hand off but then you get to take
our our drugs our blood thinners for the
rest of your life you just touched it
right there local right there local
that's it I think the key is local and
start focusing local because the thing
is too like this kind of plays in
economics as well if you have a place
that has a bad economic place and and
you're able to be like segmented off in
this other area over time they're going
to end up being a worse area to be and
people are going to more likely want to
come to your area that's a better system
that's more you know and yeah I mean
sure maybe there are people over here
like awful things and they they somehow
are successful doing awful things but
the other day that's not your concern
because you're in your local area and
you know doing what you do and drawing
people that like what you do to continue
that I agree that that is key but I
dealing with multinational corporations
that are still going to be there when we
go local I mean I'm open to abolishing
multinational corporations I don't know
what who has the authority to do that at
this point I don't think anyone
um that like they are fi or whoever
these companies are they're are that are
administering the drugs not only the
surgeries but the drugs to people for
profit are making massive amounts of
money if we don't make it illegal why
would they there's shame doesn't stop
multinational corporations
problem that that this is a a symptom of
a larger problem so focusing on like
what do we do about the uh you know the
idea that transgender used their
transgender teenagers are getting you
know bottom surgery or whatever
you what you really need to do is find
out if they're actually transgender or
not you know
mostly understand being gay pardon me
most times they end up being gay well I
mean I can't that's the stats Barrow
well yeah I mean essentially that's
that's the the short the long and short
of it but the fact that we've got
Society trying to or or elements of
society trying to encourage kids to
transition to encourage young people to
transition there is a monetary aspect of
it with the pharmaceutical companies and
with with you know hospitals that want
to do these surgeries because they're
expensive and because you're getting a
customer for life
um
but it's also the ideology that's being
you know that people are are being
taught in schools and it comes from the
culture with the the whole I think that
that the focus on LGBT identities as or
lgbtq identities as uh novel and
something to be held up in high regard
and esteem as better than normal or or
whatever that's a problem with it too
you get an A kid that's maybe maybe gay
or maybe bi or a girl that's a tomboy
and then people start whispering in
their ear oh you're transgender and if
they Tran if they if they uh if they
change you know change their sex or
whatever they they transition that's
what I was looking for if they
transition they get a bunch of attention
and stuff there are all these incentives
for people to do this and the incentives
are the things that we need to get rid
of so you can find the people that
actually are intersex that actually have
that are actually trans but that's
that's a cultural issue yes and and it
comes down to if we as a culture were
homogeneous in our morality we wouldn't
need any laws at all nobody's gonna
steal from anybody else because we all
completely agree until somebody runs out
of food yeah but but you see the issue
is in very small culturally homogeneous
systems
they they work together running out of
food isn't as big of a deal Insurance
originated as if my house burns down
help me rebuild it because if yours
burns down I'll help you rebuild it then
we codified it with with money and we
all pay into the system that ultimately
leads to as the population grows and
grows and grows a segmented fracture
Society where we don't talk to our own
neighbors and thus we have fractured a
fractured culture so now the police are
enforcing the different the the the laws
because we don't completely agree and
some people say I don't know you I don't
care about you and I need something so
I'll take it from you they don't they
don't share the values I mean you look
at Chicago you got people who use guns
to commit crimes all the time despite it
being illegal I don't care but then
you've got law-abiding citizens who
agree not to break the law and they
won't take guns this this isn't working
if everyone was on the same page and
said we should all have guns then there
would be no illegal guns there would be
no gun laws there would be no police
enforcing gun laws and everybody who
would have guns if every single person
agreed there should be no guns including
the criminals then nobody would have
guns there'd be no people getting
arrested for guns but the diff but right
now people disagree and some people
don't care so I don't know if we can
ever get to that ideological position
idealistic position of we were
culturally homogeneous anymore I don't
know I don't think so not literally but
I'm sponsored by Pfizer if you see I see
the Grammys was sponsored by Pfizer like
that's very concerning if you're talking
about impede putting information and
ideas into kids brains about who's
making the money off these surgeries off
these child gender surgeries it's come
like pharmaceutical companies in
hospitals and stuff are making money off
this for profit so unless we make it
illegal I mean are there points in
libertarianism or just in general you
guys are like we gotta we're gonna think
about this tonight are there points even
as a with a Libertarian mind that you
would use the government to make things
illegal
they won't admit it publicly we are
going to go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share this share with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
if you want to support our work and our
cultural Endeavors the coffee shop is
underway the new studio is underway we
got a new show planned for the morning
it's gonna be a lot of fun and I
appreciate all of your continued support
and let's read what you guys got to say
Goldilocks says hey Tim Jeremy put out
an apology video helped this drama
between you and the quartering can be
put behind us and we can move on as
brothers in arms Against The
Establishment I completely agree
um and I I am I say thank you to Jeremy
I I appreciate it I apologize sincerely
because I started to think about this
with the Veritas thing if Jeremy and I
agree on 99.99 of things and then I'm
just personally aggrieved because you
know whatever like I got triggered then
I'm kind of like why am I fighting with
the guy I agree with this is this is bad
for me this is bad for what I want if I
want to eventually get to the point
where I can go live in a van down by the
river I'm gonna need other people who
are going to be carrying people who will
be carrying on that fight to make sure
things don't fall apart so I kind of
felt like
you know look I can be uh aggressive and
arrogant and tell people to go screw off
it's this this apology is more about me
accepting the bigger picture and how in
the end if I think I'm going to get
anything I want or achieve anything I
can't do it by myself and fighting with
other people who agree with me is the
worst possible thing for me quite
literally a stupid position to hold so I
accept it and I have to do what I you
know I'll do what I can y'all can keep
me you all want to be mad at me keep
being mad at me by all means uh there
are still people in the chat who are who
are trying to sew uh conflict or
whatever but I'll put this way you can
you can think I'm wrong you can think
I'm lying you can think all those things
but it is 100 factually true that if we
agree with each other on core issues
then we we have to fight in the same
direction we can hate each other
afterwards after we stop you know kids
getting mutilated or whatever
all right Rusty Shackleford says Tim
please make that Eliza blue song with
John Rich that was priceless uh that was
really good John Richards ad-lib to that
song it was interesting that was good
rocket saw says I don't always watch Tim
cast IRL by the pool while smoking
venison at my apartment complex but when
I do the neighbors do too cheers that
sounds really good man
Nick Stevenson says Tim 10 bucks says
this is a targeted attack on Project
Veritas by infiltrators love your work
Nick
I kind of feel the same way and that's
what made me think I sh look you know
I'm on Twitter and I'm going off I'm
like screw everybody I don't care I
don't need to do this I don't you know
like I get so much Flack and then I
started thinking about the possibility
that I'm being manipulated or I'm being
played that the people who are trying to
get me mad at Jeremy are doing just that
because they're trying to get us to
attack each other and then I'm like I'm
not mad at Jeremy this is stupid I'm I'm
I deeply care about like watching AOC Go
on stage or in Congress and lie about
stuff I deeply care about policy that's
that's causing our economy to get worse
and I deeply care about am I going to
have a future opportunity or is this
country going to fall into a garbage
garbage dump so I'm not gonna why am I
wasting my time arguing with people who
agree with me like that's stupid I'll
say it a million times we'll just keep
reading more Super chats special shout
out to scrotes my goats by the way uh
that was fake not a real guy scrotes no
no no no no uh scrotes magotes said
someone was impersonating him and he and
sent us an email oh Wicked that's the
thing that yeah trust no one so horrible
to say but you know this is another
thing that got me going we we got an
email from our actual member saying hey
man I did not say those things and we
checked membership active everything's
good and then he was like I'm going to
actually increase my membership because
I want you guys to know I support you
and then I was like dude someone's
screwing with us so to all you scrotes
out there impersonators or no hope you
have a nice evening oh you screws yep
all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim
I should have told you earlier the P
project vertas uh stuff got me thinking
your current drama is orchestrated by
the crystal King himself Ian wants you
out I saw him and Roberto Jr having a
contract meeting oh did you keep it to
yourself yeah it's right here
yeah check it out cast Castle on uh
timcast.com hot you can also subscribe
to the channel on YouTube if you want to
see clips from older shows as they come
out later but if you want to get the the
newest episode you're going to want to
go to timcast.com Justin Bell says Tim
just wanted to say thank you for
starting this process of Healing The
Divide we all mess up and after last
week that was good
um I will disagree and say
I actually think I was being aggressive
in the beginning to begin with and I
don't like like the stuff that we're
getting sent that made me really angry
uh wasn't coming from Jeremy so for me
to then take it out of him that was my
fault in the first place so I don't
think I should get credit for a healing
healing a divide I can I can get I don't
know you can say good job on chilling
the F out I suppose look I I sincerely
mean it I don't want to fight with
people who I agree with that's stupid
all right let's see
uh where we go
Matthew Velasquez says Tim if Elon Musk
can buy Twitter then you can hire James
O'Keefe this is your Elon moment dude uh
you know I gotta be honest like when we
heard that James O'Keefe got ousted I
was like can we get him on the phone
here we don't have the legal wherewithal
to handle a project level uh um
operation when we get people coming to
us about stuff I always just direct them
to Veritas I just say guys like they're
the ones of the legal apparatus to deal
with the stuff not us however that being
said uh if James is looking to start a
new organization if you build it you
will come a non-profit that can uh I'm
willing to bet that all the donors will
follow James O'Keefe the ID the
ideological uh uh leader and founder of
the organization yeah but you know I
will say James and he's even explicit
it's not about him it's about the
movement itself and if project Veritas
continues on without James and then
James starts a new organization and now
there's two places the whistleblowers
can go to all the better Seth weather
says I hope James ate the sandwich
like that's the thing too it's like
that's why they're firing the guy
because they watched him take a sandwich
from somebody even if that was true I'd
be like what like if Ian walked up to
another employee and grabbed their
sandwich I'd just be like you don't do
that I guess
like I don't and people would be like yo
Ian took my sandwich we'd be like all
right well tell them how to do that yeah
it's kind of self-correcting I think can
you imagine if we called you in for like
a six hour meeting where we're like you
took a shot rights and we're like
slamming was on the sandwich go make
another sandwich or you ate the sandwich
all right Marion Holtzman says the
serious cases that James O'Keefe covers
I would think he needs to own a very
tight Organization for those dropping
the ball fire them
yeah I agree I absolutely agree but I
think because it's um it's a non-profit
there's three directors on the board so
if James never had full control of that
thing it was always him and at least two
other people
Jeremy Hernan says glad to see you and
Jeremy bury the hatchet love you both
you should really try again to bring him
on he says he doesn't like flying so it
is what it is but uh yeah man look there
I've had people on this show who I who I
genuinely think are bad people and it's
like
of all the people I should be mad at I
don't know I just felt in the end I'm
kind of like we we've had we've yeah
it's definitely not him yeah it's like
we've had people on the show who are
legitimate grifters who pretend like
they or literally don't know what's
going on in the world and without
calling anybody out it's typically like
you know left-leaning people man I
wanted to get in there and start calling
names out yeah it's like look there
there are some good left-wing people
we've had on the show who are genuinely
genuinely ignorant and then there's some
sophists who have been on the show in
like intentionally mislead and I'm like
that's the kind of stuff I'm mad about
you know what I mean
yeah a lot of people to come on
ignorantly and learn because that's what
I did yeah yeah I mean respect to the
Kraken scenes for listening to me just
go off for 20 minutes about Ukraine and
gas prom and the cutter turkey Pipeline
and Nordstrom and all that stuff oh and
you guys see that Seymour Hersh I think
article the US and Norway destroyed uh
Nordstrom too oh yeah yeah that's that's
bad news that's that's if that is that
news I don't know well I don't know but
the the fact the matter is if if you
give Russia more reason to accuse the
U.S of stuff then you're given then it's
going to be an escalation and so
regardless of who knew what or whatever
uh the fact that Russia can now say look
the U.S this is here's more evidence the
US is blah blah that means NATO is that
means it's justifying escalation and
this whole thing could very easily get
way out of hand and that way out of hand
is talking about the possible nuclear
exchange between the US and and Russia
whether it be unlikely or not whether
you think it's unlikely or not uh I
don't think that that really matters
because
it's like I'm like I carry a gun it's
unlikely that I'm gonna ever ever have
to use my gun but I carry the gun
because of what happens if I if I need a
gun like that's this it's like the res
the the the result of a nuclear exchange
is so catastrophic you have to treat it
as if it's always a possibility because
the result is the end of you know
possibly the end of modern civilization
we can't go to war with Russia just
absolutely not I'm willing to end the
world or sure which country owns Crimea
Phil I don't know about you I mean I was
thinking about it and I was like you
know a nuclear Annihilation and the end
of humanity is worth it for a small you
know yeah you know and the people that
sorry to go on about this but it's so
frustrating to hear people say oh well
you know Russia's gonna go and make a
move on other uh NATO countries and
stuff and it's like the reason that we
have NATO and the reason that Ukraine is
not in NATO is because of Ukraine's
history with Russia and if we were to go
ahead and say well everyone that Russia
gets into some kind of conflict with we
just go ahead and fold them into NATO
and then attack Russia that's you might
as well not have NATO and just initiate
a first strike against Russia not
ignoring that but I'm saying as I am the
might as well not have NATO party at
least yeah yeah yeah that I'm saying I'm
saying initiating the first strikes we
got this one from Nick Williams says
John fetterman is in the hospital
everyone puncher 2023 bingo card heard
that last night actually did you guys
watch the new South Park
no but I saw you Tweeting about it and I
I can't wait to watch it yeah yeah
so it's about uh Cartman has Cupid uh
cupidier which is a little is floating
around wearing his hoodie and it's very
you know it's compliant it's telling a
token that you know black people are the
real Jews or whatever
there's a scene there's a scene where
Cartman is in bed and Cupid yay is is
mentions they and then he says who is
they and so uh you know we we indirectly
got our got our mockery from I love
those guys I love it they're testing man
and then the credits I noticed something
it said like written written by Matt
Stone directed by Matt Stone with
Special Assistant to Matt Stone Trey
Parker and I'm like is that a joke or is
legit one of them just like maybe Trey
took the month off yeah right yeah maybe
all right yeah fetterman's in the
hospital man that sucks they said I
heard that he had a second stroke could
be complete BS I don't know that's just
Terror it's terrifying man so who's the
lieutenant governor or I know that uh no
that he's not the governor never mind
I'm sorry
she wants it she wants it so if he if he
if something happens to him do they have
like just another runoff or something
like that or how would they replay it or
would this would the governor appoint a
senator or I have no idea I don't know
do you know how that works Tim if
something happens what happened to John
he can't serve did someone get a point
oh yeah they have point something I
think is the governor his wife the
speculation the speculation from a lot
of people was that he would be forced
out due to a medical issue and then they
would put his wife in I I'm kidding that
was just a joke because everyone that
makes a joke that his wife runs
everything anyway she does yeah I'm
gonna be sick I think she planned it
somehow I'm gonna vomit
all right let's see uh by the way Tower
gang endorsed fetterman I just want to
throw that out there yeah for the comedy
unironically unironically I would have
voted for him Michael malice did too
didn't he I think so yeah he was like
are you kidding we gotta have that guy I
mean even then he's such a great
representative I want a congress full of
fettermans all vegetables who can't get
anything done that's perfect
this is a good one here from figgy
merman he says James O'Keefe is the only
person project Veritas has exposed as a
bad person without any video
it's the only time they've accused
someone of malfeasance without evidence
good point that's it I just I I just
don't believe it rare project Veritas L
yeah and and James O'Keefe is Project
Veritas yeah he's like often when we
talk about it we don't even say James
O'Keefe right but James O'Keefe releases
James O'Keefe expose he is the face he
doesn't want to be thought of as the
thing I know he's told me that to my
face like it's a movement that he's a
part of yeah and he's become kind of an
icon in the movement he is he is but it
is a great movement greater than all of
us
all right let's grab some more
El Jefe says part of fighting together
Tim is denouncing your plan to host a
drag show
you can't promote sexual lewdness while
claiming to fight sexual lewdness no
there's a point in that drag show so I I
said I'm gonna put on the biggest the
Jack euger The Young Turks was like if I
could afford it I'd put on a big drag
show and I'm like
okay then I'll do it we're gonna put on
the biggest drag show we're gonna hit a
bunch of uh you know drag performers and
there'll be uh free food and drinks 21
and over of course because of the the
drinking and uh there should be no
problems right nobody nobody should have
anything to complain about it's funny
when I said that no leftist said
anything they immediately just dropped
the subject is that because are you
really going to come out and rebutton be
like but let the kids in don't be like
there's alcohol but let them in anyone
so look man
I'm not a staunch conservative I have no
problem with burlesque you know if
people want to go to a show and there's
women and they do their burlesque thing
and if it's dragging them into the thing
it's just not for kids just I've heard
it's fun I don't know no kids I mean and
my cup of tea I've seen those videos and
I'm like I would not enjoy whatever that
is that's I just but I don't know some
people like watching boxing I'm not a
fan of boxing I'd rather watch MMA look
I've watched RuPaul's drag show and
that's funny that drag the drag race
that show's funny but I don't know if
I'm gonna go to a bar to see a drag show
I've heard they're pretty like there's a
place I think in like Florida called
Hamburger Mary's where they do that and
I've heard I mean some people tell me
it's like fun because they make it
comediate like comedic it's like a whole
show but it's not for kids like you know
I don't know I mean I don't know it
doesn't sound like my thing but I don't
know maybe I would enjoy it I don't know
I've never tried it
all right feeling dangerous says Hey I
just want my Super Chat red LMAO well
there you go bring Jim Jordan on again
he was awesome would love a full episode
well so you know here's what happens we
get Matt gates to come on
I'm a big fan
and I thought it was a great episode
hanging out on Friday night I could
barely talk so he's just you know
explaining all of these things when he
when he mentioned the Pelosi's or Paul
Pelosi buying that stock on the uh what
was it on the dip and then the bills get
killed don't make it to the floor that's
that's a that's crazy
so I get I get reached at uh bobert's
Team reaches out and said you know
they're going to be doing this big
hearing so we'd love to do a show with
you but getting out to you guys is very
difficult can you come to us because
here's how it basically works
for them they're getting prepped all day
for a hearing and they're sitting there
questioning you know Executives they
can't come out here until the very last
minute
but we have employees who could go there
set up and then once they're done with
their hearings run and sit down and talk
to us and they basically were like if
you can come out here and do it we'll
get like everybody to come on the show
and I was like I mean dude that sounds
incredible so uh getting to meet Jim
Jordan having him come on and explain a
lot of this stuff was really great uh
Matt Gates walked right into our
dropping a bunch of f-bombs it was it
was fantastic I'm like this guy from
Congress here is just cussing up a storm
on this live show to hundreds of
thousands of people also the staff was
awesome you guys rock and the amount of
work they do like 6 a.m to 10 11 P.M
every day like it's five days a week it
is like you might from a TV it might
look like they don't do a lot but my
Lord are they invested in what they're
doing yeah shout out to the billboard
staff by the way as well I appreciate
all the help Calvin torgenson says shout
out to Ian on his Brittany venti video
you strike me as a very genuine and
curious person thank you so much thank
you sir what was your video I made a
video about two o'clock today about the
whole thing I was getting videos me and
there's a video of me and Eliza from
back in the day where we were hugging
and like cuddling and hanging off Adam
and nishra back in their house drinking
whiskey and I was like what's up what's
wrong with Ian and I'm like I'm making a
video I'm done I'm not playing this in
text I'm not doing in text so I just
made a video as straightforward as I can
be about 30 came about 13 minutes long I
got my Periodic Chart behind me check it
out Ian Crossland on YouTube there you
go
all right what do we have John L says
have to send Phil love for his music but
Death Punch deserves credit for lining
the dream on covet and welcome to the
circus the world today
all right I love I love the guys in Five
Finger Death Punch and I appreciate the
Kudos I'm not sure exactly what you
meant but yeah competition Phil they're
they're sweethearts they're wonderful
people I love them all so
Duke says call these clowns out Tim
Trump is Trump he is just Trump flannel
guy is a clown I'll continue to give to
you if you call flannel guy out
of it you're a clown thank you
that's my favorite thing about flannel
guy though yeah we uh I I am known for
evoking reactions from people so well I
I you know flannel guy look Donald Trump
is is the greatest president we've ever
had and I think you oh man apology yeah
Donald Trump I will apologize to you if
you come on Tower gang that is my
stipulation yeah I'm so sorry I was mean
please
um I I genuinely think Trump is the best
the breast the best president of my life
oh I agree of my life I mean it's an
it's a bar that's buried under the
ground
was he like the only one who didn't sort
of start a war I mean he was ending him
you know
I'll take what I can get the low bar
like he said so it's like I'll take it
it's very low bar you know uh
there's a lot to be said about Donald
Trump I I think he really did want to
keep his promises I think he really did
try I just think he brought on bad
people I think he's he's Brash and he's
arrogant but what do you think about him
campaigning with Lindsey Graham does is
that a good sign that he's learned his
lesson or right now no and and that's
that's why we have a lot of people being
like maybe this Andis is the guy ugh
yeah who do you see as a president
nobody what about like realistically
there's Rand Paul I mean yeah like I
don't know if that's realistic but I
would be that would be way better than
anything else we have so he's just
wouldn't campaign if you don't see
someone you like I mean Dave Smith he's
talked about it I love the idea but
frankly like I've given up on the idea
of fixing our federal government I think
it's a hundred percent local I think you
gotta find a place that you think you
can invest in I'm all in on the free
state project at this point I I'm all
about like if Dave wants to run for
president and try to you know send a
message and attract people to these
ideas I think it's great but hoping that
we're gonna have any sort of like
political revolution to save this mess I
think it's just there's no way I think
it's this uh Duke here gave us another
Super Chat a huge one two hundred
dollars he really doesn't like you
that's awesome yeah well you know shout
out thanks for the super chats man you
can bring them back I want to make sure
make sure that I mean if Duke keeps
giving us this level of money I mean
maybe no I'm just kidding I'm just
kidding Duke I appreciate the Super Chat
just call me clanol flannel clown to
like you know make a little clown yeah
can you tell can you tell Reed what Duke
called him please what can you can you
tell Reed what Duke called him what the
flannel guy
that's what I'm thinking I'll have to
say the other one I'll tell you later if
we do in Tower form I think we're all
right oh yeah let's let's Tower it no no
there's kids listening there's kids yeah
you can't can't do it drish says but
he's right though drizz says bro I'm
proud of you and Jeremy call out the bad
give credit where credit is due respect
man yeah I think you guys are allowed to
be mad at me
um hopefully we can just move on and
focus the fight on uh on the issues that
that matter substantially more I I just
don't see their to be I hope I hope
Stephen crowd and the daily wire guys
eventually get to a point where they're
like you know okay whatever we're doing
important things it's just it got to
this point with Veritas where I'm just
like yo if this keeps happening we're
done yeah that's over it's over in six
months that was what my video was about
today it was a little bit about lies it
was really about Brittany getting her
account banned I'm really concerned with
social media overreach right now even
though we got a hero and Twitter a lot
of people think elon's a hero doesn't
mean that people can't go crazy so I
went on and on about that let's stay
focused on censorship and make sure
that's unrighteously backhand 187 says
first ever Super Chat the easy fix to
the Eliza blue story Tim is to have
Brittany venti on the show yes uh agreed
and we also I'm planning on having Shane
Cashman on with Chrissy mayor so I think
we can just as as a means to be like
we're gonna hash all this out because we
we we pride ourselves on being the
people who sit down and talk about
things that are controversial And We
complain when people refuse to show up
to debate these issues so we will have
that conversation and I'm hoping we can
do it next week the reality is this
would be special
um privileges in a sense and that were
booked up for like three or four weeks
out or longer but I'm pretty sure we can
find a way to to have Chrissy and Shane
come in and then do I think tomorrow
would be the best thing I don't know if
it's possible tomorrow considering one
we had this conversation today and kind
of hashed things out as it was I I
apologized Jeremy apologized I don't
know if Jeremy needs to apologize as as
much as I probably do because I was
being a dick and being very arrogant on
Twitter I can accept that but um Fridays
are good days to just kind of chill and
just talk about everything but I feel
bad for the guests we already have a
book I don't want to you know Ram them
into this conversation but we'll figure
it out maybe maybe some point next week
we'll get this uh we'll get this going
Christy's in New York that's not too far
right yeah super and and I think Shea
might be around I I I I genuinely think
as I'm as you know as I'm looking
through this like I I hope people
understand maybe maybe we'll get into
the specifics on what was being sent to
us because that triggered us that
triggered me don't like the things being
sent to my friends and and you know that
kind of stuff I'm like bro you come with
my friends I'm done I'll I will I will
shut this whole company down if people
threaten my friends and so but I got to
thinking like Jeremy didn't do that like
I'm being baited man I'm being tricked
and if someone wants to shut your
company down and they'll send you
about your friends exactly and and if
I'm not being tricked
I shouldn't be fighting with people who
agree with me because we're mad about
one thing that's stupid right I know I
said 800 times so I'll just try and
raise more super jets
Duke sent us another Super chair Tim why
the hell would you have haircut and
flannel guy on bad timing I'm done with
you bro come on you told me if I called
him out you'd keep you'd stick around
keep sending money buddy it's only
increasing our chances of coming back I
read super chats people are allowed to
criticize our guests you know what I
mean I mean obviously we're talking
about the Eliza blue thing now that that
got to a point you know but I hope I
somehow become more controversial yeah
I'm a huge fan that's not like it's
gonna happen our audience is split
between uh uh Maga and libertarian you
know there's like an overlap between
them where so I think most people are
just going to be like well you know yeah
they're Libertarians they're all right
you know we don't agree on Trump
says Tim thank you for the humility none
of us are reasonable people none of us
reasonable people wanted you to change
your opinion or disavow anyone we just
wanted acknowledgment as you are big
enough to call attention to the
censorship thank you fight on there so
we got a message from someone saying I
will not support you if you don't
disavow this person and so I said if you
don't let the door hit your ass on the
way out and then we got an email from
from that person saying yo that was not
me someone made a fake account using
that name I am still a member I'm not
leaving and we were like ah that made me
be like yo we're getting played
we're getting played people are faking
us we're getting played man but whatever
you know what if if there are people who
are legit legit legitimately mad or
whatever then then they can keep being
mad at me I just I don't know whatever
I'm a guy complaining in it for a living
all right Jay Walker says tell Phil he
accidentally blocked me on the Bird app
at Walker Jerry it wasn't an accident
that's what I was thinking the thing is
for my my opinion on the Bird app is the
same as uh Michael malice it is like
block Loosely for whatever because the
my experience on the Bird app is my
experience it's not your experience and
I have no desire to listen to people
that are just gonna flame me if you if
you come and say something polite I'll
respond I probably respond more than
most people on on the Bird app too much
but if you come and you're snarky and I
don't know you or you think that you
know me and stuff I might just go ahead
and block you so you know something I
realized through all this is that your
your social media status with someone is
not indicative of your friendship with
them I have friends that I am not on
social not friends on social media
because we just annoy each other in text
but they're my friend he's my good
friend like yep me and Jason Richard
Jason Richardson doesn't follow me on
Twitter because I I drive him nuts but
we just spent all last week hanging out
being buddy buddy you know big hugs when
I see him big hugs when I leave because
we get along famously when we're hanging
out together we just disagree on some
political stuff and so he doesn't follow
me and I don't I'm not mad at him for it
you know all right last one Mike Daly
says your podcast last night was one of
the most important podcasts ever thank
you uh two of the microphones didn't
work and uh we know why it's it's a it's
a it's a
um a driver issue with the channels that
the computer doesn't pick up two of them
and you only get two or whatever but uh
the good news is you see the members of
Congress we're really excited to be able
to do a show in that fashion imagine if
Tucker Carlson was like we're bringing
the studio to your office you can come
on the show they'd be like whoa
but it's harder for him to do that
easier for us albeit it was difficult I
mean Surge and Andrew really pulled it
together and and busted ass to make that
happen yeah very last second honestly
what was that like uh it was great I got
to walk around in Congress I got the
Dunkin Donuts in there yeah that's cool
they have a Baskin robbers David Duncan
in Congress yeah yeah people are buying
like uh you know literally pints of ice
cream it was kind of crazy to see as a
New Englander I'm happy to hear that
Duncan yeah yeah it smells good but
we're gonna do it again because
following that we get some messages from
other uh staffers being like why didn't
we think of this can we do it again I'm
like you tell me when because this is
why we came to the DC we're about an
hour or so outside of DC our 20 hour 30.
and I'm like that's the point because
this is the the seat of politics I hate
to see DC by the way but we can do
things like this so I think we're
probably gonna get more shows and
they'll be set up way better with better
lighting this was like a last minute
thing where it was like Friday hey can
you come out and I'm like I'm see if we
can figure it out Serge had to figure
out building the mobile setup and
getting all the equipment we didn't even
know where the equipment was we're like
we gotta go find it because it's in
storage it took a while I was so
stressed guys my hair fell out that's
right that's right but now that we've uh
gone through that gone through all that
we uh we're talking with other members
and we think we'll be able to set up the
show and and and do another one
relatively soon which would just be
really really great so the idea is the
next time there's a big hearing and we
want follow-up and conversation on that
stuff like especially the weaponization
of government commit uh hearings right
that's the most important thing in my
opinion going right now exactly imagine
we set up right after they do those
hearings we sit down with Matt Gates Jim
Jordan bobert Etc and the crew Anna
Paulina Luna and uh uh are able to talk
about these Byron Donald's and cross
aisle that's really exciting a lot of
people in the chat were super chatting
they want to see like people from both
sides of the political aisle coming
together and talking about these crazy
things I mean if they if they can get a
Democrat who wants to come on and they
agree to have a conversation about the
weaponization of government and we agree
to keep that in the con like
I would I would be look my concern is if
we had someone like ilhena Omar AOC we'd
get into the tribal issues we'd get into
cultural issues that we disagree on but
if there are is Common Ground where we
can solve a real problem and we agree
okay we'll put aside these other things
and we'll specifically talk about the
thing we agree on and agree not to
attack each other I think at least that
conversation is better than nothing
maybe there's an opportunity there like
talking about war foreign policy and
stuff and then we'll be like agree not
to go after a cultural character and
things like that but I'll leave it there
my friends if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and become a member at
timcast.com if you want to watch the
members only uncensored show where we'll
tell you how we really feel uh I'm not
I'm I'm kidding but we will swear a lot
more we did swear a bit in this episode
because I figured you know what screw it
you know Matt went off a little bit
started swearing we'll swear towards the
end of this one but we're going to talk
about some more cultural issues over at
timcast.com which should be up in about
one hour so thank you all for your
support you can follow the show at
timcastirl you can follow me personally
at timcast uh Tower game guys you want
to shout anything out uh yeah um we have
the tower gang show uh it goes on
YouTube and Rumble live at um every
Wednesday at 9 11. uh I also have my
other show no way Jose uh yeah you get
it that's a real time is obvious uh but
anyways uh then I have my no way Jose
show uh you know that's on YouTube all
the major art packagers obviously as
well go check out my OKC playlist uh and
you follow me at Tower gang Jose if you
want to follow me on Twitter yeah and
I'm also a co-host on Tower gang I have
my show the naturalist capitalist that
is on YouTube Rumble Odyssey for video
it's on all um audio streaming platforms
as well also I'm on free talk live every
Thursday night out of Keene New
Hampshire from seven to ten
um and I do the four horsemen show once
a month with my friends Ryan Dawson and
Eric Jackman go check them out on
Twitter they're at Rye Liberty and at
Jackman radio
um and uh you can follow me on Twitter
at read Coverdale also on Instagram and
on uh Telegram
at read Coverdale and uh if you think
Libertarians are kind of lame and gay
sometimes that's right so go follow the
libertarian party New Hampshire because
we're way more based and bold than the
rest of the Libertarians out there at
lpnh and check out the free state
project think about moving to New
Hampshire if you want to make a
difference for Liberty in your lifetime
that's all I got to say
I am filled that remains the band is All
That Remains Phil it remains on Twitter
uh Phil that remains official on
Instagram uh check out the band All That
Remains it's heavy it's metal you'll
love it you'll mosh Phil I'm glad you're
back I love you I think you're gonna be
here for a while I have nothing planned
for like all that remainsy stuff for the
next at least month and a half oh you're
playing me one before the show I like
yeah we we were busy out there we got
some cool stuff man we got there's
there's some really great the best All
That Remains is still yet to come the
best metal that All That Remains is has
made is still yet to come our days are
going to be great oh I want to scream
with you yeah let's do this I'm so glad
you guys came this was awesome we
appreciate it it was great great
conversation awesome okay so guys go
subscribe my YouTube channel Ian
Crossland check out the video earlier
today I'm looking for a ux Dev if you
want to get involved hit me up on
Twitter or on mines and uh also I think
that's about it we need an open source
large language model we'll get into that
a little later bye everyone
and of course I am at surge.com uh sorry
about the technical issues yesterday
it's fine it'll work out next time uh
follow me on Twitter I'm almost at like
4K which is crazy I never thought that
would happen in my life but uh yeah see
you there we will see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out
cheers